okay
good morning everyone welcome to the
Monday April 10th edition of the science
technology and energy committee
we'll be getting to four Senate bills
that we'll be discussing here this
morning we'll get to those in just a
moment but first we'll start our meeting
as always by asking everyone to rise and
join representative Lex barajny as he
leads us in our Pledge of Allegiance
liberty and justice for all
okay thank you and
Welcome to our
second meeting to discuss bills that
have been forwarded to us by our friends
on the other side of the wall as it's
called
and uh
we will be discussing four bills here
this morning Senate Bill 113 relative to
cost Effectiveness review of The Joint
utility Energy Efficiency plan we'll
follow that with Senate Bill 161
relative to low moderate income
Community solar projects then we'll move
on to Senate Bill 166 relative to
electric grid modernization
and wrap it up after that with Senate
Bill 167 relative to Green hydrogen
energy and infrastructure so let's get
started with Senate bill 113.
and even though I do not have a pink
card from him I'm going to assume that
senator abard from
District 12 will introduce this bill to
US senator avard thank you Mr chairman
and yes I will be introducing it seeing
how I am the Prime on this and uh well
the record I'm Senator Kevin abar from
District 12.
greetings to you all nice to see you all
smiling this morning
all right I trust you all had a
wonderful uh Easter
again I I am the prime sponsor for uh
sb113 um
uh last year the legislator legislature
acted quickly to correct the uh is that
too loud uh to quickly correct an order
from the puc which severely restricted
the New Hampshire saves Energy
Efficiency program and it jeopardize
many of the contractors who worked for
the program
HB 549 restored the funding for the New
Hampshire safes program and provided
clarity
on administrative Administration going
forward
contained in HB 549 was a provision that
required the program's planned electric
savings to be at least 65 percent of the
overall savings the puc interpreted this
change to apply to a planned Lifetime
and annual Savings of the program not
just the planned annual savings every
party in the puc docket testified in
support of applying the legislative
change to annual savings
and while the statute does not
specifically uh specify whether the
annual or lifetime savings should be
used the puc interpretation
interpretation differed from every
single party to the docket and limits to
the New Hampshire State program's
Effectiveness which reduces uh benefits
to customers and negatively impacts home
builders remodelers who perform the work
because of the savings from the
weatherization improvements last uh
because of the savings from
weatherization improvements last for at
least decades rather than just years and
it's difficult to balance the percentage
of the lifetime electric savings at 65
percent
and whether whetherisation is important
tool to help customers manage their
energy costs and improve the comfort and
value of their homes
through the homes performance with
energy star programs customers receive
comprehensive audits of their homes and
rebates to reduce the cost of
recommended building improvements like
insulation and ceiling air spaces in
many of the rebates making home more
comfortable and less drafty which
results also in lower energy uses
weatherization improvements result in
savings for customers and overall energy
use and the New Hampshire safe programs
are the only source of State supported
customer for customers to increase
efficiency in their home and the vast
majority of the cities and towns across
the state utilize the HW hpes programs
the pdc's interpretation of the
legislation changed last year puts this
state support for weatherization at risk
which diminishes the value of the
programs to the customers and again it
jeopardizes the same contractors that
were intended to be protected under HB
the provisions added to HB 549 and puc's
interpretations changed how the programs
have been administered in the past
adding annual to the savings
requirements would restore these
programs enable the contractors to
continue to meet customers expectations
the weatherization programs offered
through New Hampshire saves supports
good paying local construction jobs and
helps electric customers control their
overall energy spending in particular
the importance in the face of the
current High inflation and elevated
Energy prices we all know that that's
happening right now
without these weatherization programs
customers would pay even higher energy
bills and those who cannot afford to pay
these bills would need to seek
additional state and local assistance
this will strain New Hampshire's
low-income energy assisted programs
putting pressure on the state and local
budgets and result in increase in a
number of unpaid bills which could be
borne by
taxpayers
if you look at some of the uh at our
committee reports there was no nobody
that came in to oppose this bill
and
the department of energy was neutral on
it and basically it's just a simple
language fix
and I I believe to increase I don't know
if he's here or not but with the
consumer advocate he he also came in in
support of it
um Matt Mayberry here's as well he's the
vice president of the New Hampshire Home
Builders Association and he also is
here to support it as well
uh
to simple fix we're just asking you to
to vote with us and uh
thank you
thank you Senator good introduction
um we I'm sure have a few questions but
before we do that I would just remind
you that we do need a pink card for our
record-keeping purposes when you want me
to write a pin card yes okay we can do
that I have the technology
and I have one quick question before I
turn it over to representative McGee was
this bill amended by the senate or is
what we're seeing here the bill as
introduced it's as introduced by me as
introduced okay great thank you
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question
um the rep representative of Oz or
chairman Vose and I both serve on the
easy board and we heard about this in
the easy board from the utilities
specifically because they said their
attorneys were unable to figure out how
to interpret
the interpretation so that they could
Implement so uh can you just comment on
how it looks like it's a one-word fix
right it's to clarify that annual
savings is what we're looking for so
that it can't be interpreted in any
other way is that that is correct yeah
it's uh it's it's a simple fix and just
uh I guess you know belts and suspenders
is what what it's needed and uh and this
is I think it's an important program
okay thank you thank you
additional questions from the committee
representative Corman has one thank you
Mr chairman and thank you senator abard
for taking my question so
when I think about the lifetime savings
that's over a number of years correct
right over decades or decades so
if the annual Energy savings are below
65 percent each year that implies that
the lifetime savings are under 65
percent as well do I have that right I
don't believe so I think the cumulative
effect is what you'll see the savings
over over a decade Decades of period but
I think there's some people that can
talk a little bit more specific about
the uh
the percentage better than I can
actually okay yeah but thank you for the
question
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question I do thank you Mr chair
um I
in in this bill it says that you're
using the granite state test does that
um can you point me to where that exists
I cannot okay all right all right fair
enough
um but it's a standard that's used yeah
I believe so okay yeah all right thank
you
additional questions from the committee
for the prime sponsor of this
legislation
seeing none I want to thank you senator
raybard for being here thank you very
much and I will look forward to filling
out that pin card thank you all right
and I will see you tomorrow morning
okay
next up
Griffin robarge from the uh Department
of energy
good morning good morning thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee uh for
the record Griffin Roberge from the New
Hampshire Department of energy the
department is neutral to sent Bill 113
as introduced as this committee is aware
the puc issued in order back in November
of 2021 that's order 26.
553 that significantly altered the
funding levels for the
2021-2023 triennial Energy Efficiency
plan
that plan sought to establish new
funding levels for programmatic outlines
for ratepayer fund and Energy Efficiency
programs in the state these programs
which are operated jointly amongst New
Hampshire's Electric utilities known as
New Hampshire saves offer a suite of
different Financial incentives and
rebates for Energy Efficiency measures
in residential commercial and Industrial
properties
in response to this order the New
Hampshire General Court passed and
Governor soon who signed into law House
Bill 549 from last year that bill
restored programmatic stability to these
New Hampshire saves programs but most
importantly House Bill 549 represented a
clear demonstration by this legislature
of its policy-making Authority and
setting the system benefits charge which
is the charge that all electric
customers pay to fund Energy Efficiency
programs and in setting in statute
certain elements that the puc must use
when it evaluates these Energy
Efficiency programs including the cost
Effectiveness standards to evaluate
program savings which is the Genesis of
Senate Bill 113 here today
um
following House Bill 549's passage the
puc issued another order that's order
26.
621 in April of last year that approved
the 2022 to 2023 Statewide Energy
Efficiency plan the puc made interpret
made an interpretation of House Bill
549's language on the cost Effectiveness
that will have impacts on New Hampshire
saves program offerings in the future
and again that's the purpose of Senate
Bill 113 here today is to provide that
legislative Clarity on that cost
Effectiveness language if you look at
the bill obviously it's very it's a very
small change but on lines 10 to 12 of
the bill the legislature required quote
in no instance shall an electric
utilities planned Electric System
savings fall below 65 percent of its
overall plan Energy savings in the puc's
April order again that's 26 621 the puc
interpreted the statutory language to
require that all electric utility
program offerings must quote meet the
requisite electric energy savings
threshold of 65 percent in both annual
electric energy savings and lifetime
electric energy saving categories in the
2024 uh to 2026 triennial plan
so utilities per House Bill 549 are
required to submit their
2024-2026 trial triennial Energy
Efficiency plans to the puc by July 1 of
this year so what does that mean
um the general court obviously required
on lines 10 to 12 and House Bill 549
they required a balance between electric
savings and overall Energy savings
whereby 65 percent of the overall Energy
savings must be electric savings this
provision codified a long-standing puc
imposed threshold for Energy Efficiency
programs offered by the electric
utilities in the state in past years
this threshold has been reviewed using
annual electric and Energy savings
meaning that for a three-year plan such
as 21 to 23 the electric Savings in 21.
22 and 23 would make up more would make
up 65 or more of all Energy savings in
all three of those years in other words
the 65 percent threshold was reviewed by
examining annual plan savings
the puc when an interpreted House Bill
549 and its April order inserted the
concept of Lifetime savings into the
evaluation of this threshold this means
that measures that have uh and this
means Energy Efficiency measures that
have a longer useful lifespan will count
more when evaluating whether the 65
threshold has been met for example
whether a residential weatherization
efforts you tend to have a longer useful
life and have a higher percentage of
non-electric savings than other purely
electric folks focused offerings like
High Energy Efficiency lighting fixtures
by measuring both Lifetime and annual
Savings of an improvement energy
conservations that have a longer
lifetime like insulation and other
weatherization efforts May drag down the
overall portfolio's ability to achieve
that 65 percent savings threshold in
other terms longer term life-lived
programs like weatherization and
insulation they achieve non-electric
savings may need to be reduced in New
Hampshire safe's future future
portfolios so that New Hampshire saves
can achieve that 65 threshold and will
likely gain puc approval when the
utilities file on July 1.
um simply this would really negatively
impact residential weatherization
programs like the home energy assistance
program that's offered by New Hampshire
saves
um samp Bill 113 uh clarifies that
legislative intent by requiring that the
65 threshold applies to plan annual
Energy savings by doing so
weatherization programs will likely
remain in a portfolio that achieves that
65 balance as has been done for many
years in the puc
I've gone on for quite a bit I'm done
I'll take any questions
thank you we appreciate your testimony
and I'm sure representative Corman wants
to follow up to understand why
if the legislature if anything done in
the legislature only applies to the
Future not the past
then if a utility is achieving 65
electric Savings in each annual
increment going forward how can that not
result in a 65 Lifetime Achievement so
thank you for the question so I I would
submit that
the the
puc's interpretation in its April order
um certainly doesn't preclude obviously
uh different types of programs uh being
offered by the electric utilities the
concern is that that 65 threshold when
applied to both annual and lifetime
savings could detrimentally impact
um
I don't want to say non-electric Energy
Efficiency programs like weatherization
efforts offered like I said to the home
energy assistance program
um
obviously I'm sure the utilities might
be able to offer a program that meets
the new puc imposed thresholds but it
would detrimentally impact many of their
program offerings that look at
weatherization efforts and Residential
Properties
representative Doug Thomas has a
question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so
um I apologize if I feel like I'm a
little bit thick-headed and what you're
really saying but
based on what you just said
is that mean to imply that for the
non-electric savings are you implying
that over the years
that
efficiency because of the age of of of
the project the defense sheet would go
down over the years enough to wear over
a lifetime it wouldn't meet the 65
savings on the average because as you go
farther like say 10 20 years down the
line whatever weather weatherization you
may have done to your house may have an
exponential lesser effect over the years
because of age of the product or
whatever I'm trying to find out no
that's fine so I I thank you for the
question I think the uh best way to
clarify it is that the puc is now
requiring that those savings to achieve
that 65 threshold you're measuring on
annual basis and a lifetime basis now
whereas in previous years it tends to be
just annual the puc when issued its
April order interpreted again Lifetime
and annual because weatherization
efforts you know like insulation that
type of thing tend to have a longer
useful life than say
Energy Efficiency lighting which may
last maybe you know
broadly maybe five to seven years for
lighting but weatherization efforts
might last you know a couple decades
that could reduce the ability to meet
that lifetime that 65 percent Lifetime
and annual thresholds that the puc
create by reconverting it and clarifying
that it's annual savings you would allow
those programs to remain in utilities
program offerings
okay additional questions from the
committee representative Munn says one
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here
um
I I along with representative Doug
Thomas have struggled with this a little
bit and
um is it
is it fair to say that the puc's
interpretation increases the the
increases the the denominator in the in
the equation that needs to be done the
the the the the it's the overall savings
from weatherization if you do it over a
lifetime that increases the total amount
of savings so that when you compare that
to the annual the elective savings
you're getting from Electric it's going
to depress the uh the the calculation
that's correct okay thank you
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman
um I've worked in this sector for 25
years
um and
I appreciate representative mun's
question because the nature of my
question to you
was going to be something like no
wouldn't you
agree that
it's really difficult for
people who aren't deeply familiar with
the way these programs are
operated and evaluated to understand
this
debate without actually seeing the like
the the equations
that that are and and some actual
figures that are being used
um you know we've got a distinction here
that electric savings must be 65 percent
of overall savings so the other savings
we're talking about are heating savings
right
heating versus electric use and part of
this controversy if there's a
controversy or a policy disagreement is
that
the system benefits charges levied only
on electric bills
and that's why we have that's why this
requirement gets in there from a policy
standpoint well we have to make sure
that electric savings are the majority
of the savings as opposed to all savings
um it's just it I mean it's a really
difficult
you're nodding so I'm like getting that
you kind of agree that it's just a
really something it's hard for people to
wrap their heads around you know what
what are we even talking about here 65
of of versus annual and Lifetime and you
know representative months say what is
the denominator right yeah no and I I
thank you for the question I would
submit yes it is it is uh I would submit
holistically energy policy is not the
easiest policy to comprehend
um
I I you know but I I would go back to
the fact that the legislature you know
decided to exercise its policy making
authority to uh address an earlier puc
order made in November of 2021
um to issue definitive guidance to the
Public Utilities Commission as to how
um they review these plans when they're
submitted every three years
um you know in other words we went down
the rabbit hole Yeah
um that is one argument one could make
um but you know I these you know I would
submit the legislature clearly imposed
its its its policy making authority to
give the puc that that that Clarity
obviously the puc in its November no
April order I'm sorry last year
um interpret it a certain way this is uh
Senate Bill 113 represents another
effort by the legislature to further
clarify that legislative right thank you
yep thank you
additional questions representative
McGee has one thank you Mr chairman and
thank you Mr Roberts for taking my
question
um I have heard in testimony here that
um the weatherization programs give a
certain percentage of benefit and
um the electric savings programs in many
cases have been built out in terms of
people taking advantage of some of those
so I was wondering whether you could
speak to
um
any effects there might be on that
non-65 right so we're limiting the
ability to do more weatherization
because we have a cap on how much of
that SBC that can be can be used towards
weatherization and I wonder if there's
any data on the benefits of the
weatherization in terms of how much
demand we're offsetting that kind of
thing do we do we have any analysis of
the benefits that we're actually gaining
back for people sure sure by doing the
non-electric yeah no that's fine thank
you for the question I think I'd respect
I'm sure there are many others behind me
who are more involved in that field
um specifically the utilities who I'm
sure have read the readily accessible
data on that I think that'd be a better
question than maybe ask them here today
um but yes I would I would submit that
you know the way the POC has interpreted
it it will require the utilities to
amend their program offerings at the
detriment of of their weatherization
programs and again a lot of these
weatherization programs tend to benefit
those at the lower end of the economic
ladder those of low-income or moderate
means so and follow-up follow up so in
that case if it is the lower end of
income ladder than we would be
lowering their bills if we were able to
do more weatherization yes and you know
obviously the department offers its
weatherization assistance program or WAP
we use the federal dollars
um oftentimes the department and some in
many different programs will often
collaborate or collaborate with New
Hampshire saves and their program
offerings to kind of
cover the remaining elements of a given
project and that type of thing because
you know weatherization assistance
programs dollars have Federal strings
that we can only go up to a certain
point with our dollars and then New
Hampshire saves can maybe come in and
cover the Tail land of a project okay
thank you
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um this this bill seems like a a
clarification bill um to make to make
things a lot stronger um just wondering
why your department is neutral and not
supportive of it sure so I I thank you
for the question I think the department
is taking a neutral stance in that
because the legislature again
uh not to steal what representative
Reynolds meant before but jumped into
the rabbit hole and decided to exercise
its policy making Authority last year
regarding the system benefits charge and
how the puc should be reviewing
um these plans we defer to the
legislature in making that policy call
obviously providing input on what the
impacts from their policy choices would
be but again deferring to the
legislature to make that policy decision
seeing no further questions from the
committee I want to thank you for being
here to testify this morning next I'll
call on Mr Matt Mayberry who's here to
represent the New Hampshire Home
Builders Association
welcome Mr Mayberry
there we go good morning chairman good
morning committee members my name is
Matt Mayberry I'm the Executive Vice
President of the New Hampshire Home
Builders Association
I represent the 36 000 men and women who
work in the Residential Building Trades
I encourage you please support
113 and this one word change that one
word makes a good effective program much
more efficient and reaches out to more
of our friends and neighbors here in New
Hampshire
5860 New Hampshire families relied on
this program to stay in their homes
if programs like this weren't available
to them
they would be going to your towns your
cities your Boris Luckman and asking for
help to stay in their homes
it's the only way it works
so we're asking for this one word change
please because again it makes a good
effective program more efficient and
reach more New Hampshire families
that's it
easiest testimony you're going to have
all morning
thank you my pleasure chairman questions
for Mr Mayberry
seeing none I'll thank you and we'll
move on perfect testimony then it was
perfect estimated thank you committee
members have a good day
next we'll call on eversource
represented by Michael Licata and Mark
leminger
welcome gentlemen
good morning uh Michael licato
representing eversource with me today is
Mark Le manager Mark is the senior
analyst for Regulatory and planning at
eversource and Mark helps put together
the triennial plan so he really is a
subject matter expert on how we manage
and administer the Energy Efficiency
programs
um
I had
things to say but uh Mr robarge and
Senator avard really covered the
majority of them I was going to talk
about the the house bill last year that
tried to
provide some clarification and rectify
some of the issues that were created as
part of puc order
26553 but again that was covered so I
think I'll really
um
Focus uh my testimony and then obviously
open it up for for questions which Mark
will answer uh on on representative
corman's question
um around
why this is problematic to apply this
new requirement of 65 electric savings
on a lifetime basis and it's a very
reasonable logical question of if you're
hitting that every year 65 over the
lifetime why wouldn't uh why wouldn't it
balance out and it simply
um you know just to boil it down in
simplest terms and I think this was a
little bit covered before but just to
clarify it really does have to do with
the life of the
um uh project getting installed so if
you imagine
insulating a wall what is the life of
that insulation in that wall could be 20
30 even even longer and so you assume in
the modeling and in the plan the
lifetime savings which can be quite
large and those are largely thermal
savings now compare that to say
providing a rebate for a more energy
efficient energy star refrigerator or a
washing machine the the life of that
installation might be say five seven
years and so when you have those those
different lifetimes of the different
programs all of the savings that you're
going to accumulate from the uh the
insulation in the wall that occur after
the washing machine or the refrigerator
breaks down and needs to get replaced
sort of wash out the electric saving so
it really has to do with the length of
the life of the thermal program the
thermal installations because they are
so long so it's easy so we we can
balance on an annual basis because each
year you're sort of comparing Apples to
Apples that year so it really does
become a challenge for the utilities to
try to to balance that out and even with
that lifetime savings we can get pretty
close because uh we're able to
uh you know try to to mix uh commercial
and Industrial which tend to have more
electric savings think of electric Drive
Motors that use a lot of electricity and
we can balance that with the residential
savings which tend to be more more
thermal
other utilities have a greater and I
believe you'll hear from the Electric
Co-op a greater number of residential
customers so it becomes exceedingly
difficult so it really does become a
challenge based upon Lifetime and adding
this this one simple
um uh
uh word to the statute would really
provide a great deal of clarification
and allow as Mr Mayberry said good
programs to work even better going
forward and with that I'd be happy to
answer well actually Mark's going to be
happy to answer any questions you may
have
great thank you very much representative
Corman has a question thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr locata so I
believe I understand your explanation
but let me just make sure so let's say I
insulate a wall and that's gonna last
for 30 40 years and I get an energy star
appliance that lasts for seven years
so for those first seven years it's very
possible that
the savings uh the electric savings from
the appliance are at least 65 percent of
the total then the appliance goes away
and now
zero percent of the total is electric
because it's all due to the insulation
is that correct
that's correct I can put numbers around
it at least me visually seeing numbers
helps to explain it in theory if you had
just two lines one of if you saved for
on your electric for your refrigerator
it's very high but just uh for the
refrigerator example but if you save 650
kilowatt hours
per year
and then if you also save 350 mmbtus per
year you are meeting the 65 annual
requirement but if your electric savings
lasts for 10 years
and your mmbtu savings lasts for 20
years over the lifetime of your project
you're only going to have 6 500 kwh
saved but 7 000 mmbtu saved so you're
actually under 50 on a lifetime basis
yep no problem
numbers help thank you representative
Doug Thomas has a question thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
uh
at the risk of overstating uh
representative Coleman's explanation
which was good
to keep it really simple in in in my
head can we safely say that
the way the current bill reads
kind of assumes that all savings
projects are equal uh and all savings
projects involve electric savings and
because of that we know that's not true
and it skews what what could happen to
uh downline I need to get that answered
in my head so I can look at it that way
so when sorry when uh House Bill 549 was
passed last year
um and then the 22-23 plan docket was
being heard at the commission every
party to the docket interpreted
that bill language to mean annual it did
not nobody no party in that docket
interpreted it as annual and lifetime
the order however did interpret it that
way
um and the rationale and the
understanding is all projects on a
portfolio basis across residential
commercial and our income eligible
programs as well you understand that
there's different opportunities and
different options for customers there
one of our most cost effective measures
is weatherization on the residential
side but under the current
interpretation it provides the wrong
Energy savings so we need to balance
the types of savings we're achieving
along with cost Effectiveness to make
sure that we're delivering a return on
investment for customers but now also
making sure that we're delivering the
appropriate savings levels as well
additional questions representative
McGee has one
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question nice to see you again
Mr leminger since we have your expertise
here today I had brought up a question
earlier
um that we had heard testimony in Prior
hearings about
um the 65 and I'm curious whether
um you can illuminate for us uh whether
that is in any way problematic in terms
of the Energy Efficiency projects that
you undertake because I think the intent
by this body was to make sure that
electric rate payers were paying a
majority of the system benefits charged
towards electric savings but as those
diminish does it become harder to find
projects that meet the criteria I just
want to understand
for a ballpark for eversources customer
base we have approximately 10 to 15
percent of our customers heat with
electricity at the moment okay we've
largely addressed those customers over
the years meaning the pool of customers
for weatherization work tends to be
predominantly
non-electric heating customers so if
they are to undertake weatherization
work
under the current interpretation it's
providing the wrong
savings
um that we're looking for so it becomes
almost counter-intuitive
um
where you need to disincentivize
helping customers that
have the wrong type of heat right
thank you
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question following up on on
that and and perhaps taking us down a
rat hole that we don't want to go down
is there anything magical about the 65
percent
it's it's a requirement that was in the
law the understanding that from
asking my legal team what the
interpretation could mean it's it's
trying to keep Reliance on the fact that
electric customers are paying the SBC so
therefore electric customers should be
benefiting and the Electric System
should be benefiting as well and having
it on an annual basis still provides
that Clarity in context there's just no
electric measure I'm aware of that can
can stand up over 20 years like
weatherization does so if you're looking
at it on a lifetime basis it's kind of
an uneven playing field just because of
the the length of the measures we have
plenty of options to address 65 annual
because
just going down the list of options for
cost Effectiveness we have a pretty
lengthy list of options just to balance
out with the weatherization it's
pretty difficult
representative original has a question
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question I think I understand
the lifetime equation can you use the
same example you gave and how that would
work with the annual version or how that
changes with this bill passes thank you
sure so I'll go through the the same
example again
um on the annual basis so if you have
650 annual kwh savings and you also got
weatherization work that amounted to 350
annual mmbtu savings for your heating
fuel if you use something other than
electricity that would be the annual
equation so you would be realizing 65
percent electric savings under that
scenario
The Dilemma occurs when you now go out
how many years do those measures
maintain their cost Effectiveness above
the Baseline and your weatherization is
counted for 20 years so you're looking
at 7 000 mmbtus over the lifetime of
that measure
but for electric savings it's a much
shorter lifespan and in my very basic
example we used 10 years and you're
winding up with less than half of your
your savings coming from Electric on a
lifetime basis but back to the annual
you're at 65 percent at the front so you
you are getting
um
by having the 650 kwh per year
it's just for a shorter number of years
I'm sorry if that follow-up yeah thank
you um I guess my question is so in the
first let's say for the refrigerator for
this first seven years the annual would
make sense but what about for the eighth
year and after that wouldn't that be the
same problem not now on those years
you're now getting under because now the
fridger is no longer providing the
savings yeah so the the refrigerator
savings would drop off to zero after
year seven in that example if it was a
seven year measure life we were able to
claim the savings and verify that
they're there for the seven years above
Baseline the refrigerator doesn't
necessarily die you don't need to
replace it but above the Baseline model
you were able to claim seven years for
that efficiency and after those seven
years regardless of whether the fridge
is still there and running fine or not
we're not able to claim any more savings
so it starts counting as a zero if you
will
representative Christian has a question
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question
um I just wanted to ask about the logic
of the weatherization lifetime only
considering heat
um since we're seeing Trends toward
electrification if he wouldn't it be
reasonable to assume that you know
weatherization project that's on a house
that's using oil now might actually save
on electricity down the line if in 10
years they switch over to a heat pump or
something like that
yes so if if the trends continue and
electrification continues with with heat
pump technology and other Technologies
then somebody who weatherized their home
this year very well could be saving on
electricity if they replace their their
Heating
fuel over the next 20 years
follow-up so it seems that it's kind of
impossible to accurately calculate
lifetime then right is that
we have to use what we know at the time
which is the current heating fuel for
the customer we can't assume somebody's
going to switch from from oil to natural
gas or natural gas to electric or
anything else we have to assume what
they have in place when it comes time to
replace they'll they'll replace it with
the same type of equipment
representative Corman has another
question
thank you Mr chairman so I'm not an Ever
Source customer but I actually have
three ways to heat my house I have
electric in my upstairs I have a furnace
in my basement that's oil and forced hot
air for the basement and ground floor
and I have a wood stove so where I to
weatherize
I'm saving on all three of those sources
um
and of course the electric utility has
no idea how much wood I'm buying and has
no idea how much oil I'm buying from my
oil vendor over in Vermont
so how can we even calculate that
so we would model that based on what
amount of fuel or Collective fuel you
would consume currently and then we can
assume the efficiency to be gained by
weatherizing your property and then we
can then allocate across the fuel types
that you currently consume what do we
assume would be saved for each of those
fuels and each one carries a different
mmbt value they they kind of are worth
different amounts but luckily I'm far
enough away removed from that
mathematical modeling itself I know
enough about it to explain it to others
but I don't work in the model on a
day-to-day basis
okay
all right seeing
do you have a question
oh one more question from representative
McGee just from what you were just
testifying about it sounds to me as
though you're being given or the
modelers are being given a lot more work
uh in order to try and satisfy leaving
the lifetime language or interpretation
uh without being addressed so in other
words if we uh pass this bill today and
clarify that it is annual savings that
you're required to track then all this
the other machinations that you've been
running through trying to adapt to what
came out in that order will be satisfied
yeah so it would provide us with
additional flexibility it would preserve
the programs as they've historically
operated
um and it would preserve the funding
that we're able to provide within the
weatherization programs
okay thank you
okay
seeing no more further no further
questions I should say from the
committee I want to thank you for being
here to testify and answer our questions
appreciate it next we'll call on
Michael Krauss from the office of the
consumer advocate
good morning Mr Krause
good morning chairman good morning
everyone I believe Senator avard and the
department of energy and our fine
friends at eversource did a great job
explaining a lot of the points that I
could have tried to explain to you today
but uh just to keep it simple the OCA
does emphatically support this bill as
everyone has mentioned these
weatherization programs are mature and
should this change not come into effect
they could be at risk mostly due to that
funding issue and how do you calculate
those end results I'll keep my testimony
short and to the point so I don't repeat
everything that's been said so if you
all have any questions for me I'm happy
to engage and save you all the rest of
the time thank you
thank you questions for the office of
the consumer Advocate Mr Krause
seeing none thank you very much thank
you everyone appreciate you being here
next step
is
and I'm going to apologize in advance if
I don't pronounce this correctly
correctly but it looks like Joe
mayola
from the New Hampshire Electric Co-op
ah
our studio wanted to be down here
okay great thank you
just to clarify in the future
um
if you don't want to speak you can sign
the blue sheet rather than submitting a
pink card
that might
be more useful to everyone
all right next up is Nick Crick off of
the conservation law Foundation
and I believe you have submitted Nick
written testimony is that correct
yes I have chairman
um thank you good morning chairman good
morning committee members I'll be very
brief because I don't want to repeat
what others have already said this
morning
um but one thing I want to reiterate
here is that SB 113 merely seeks to
accomplish the purpose of the
legislation from last year HP 549 that
was overwhelmingly approved
um you know as Mr Robert said following
the passage of HB 549
the Public Utilities Commission
interpreted the bill in such a way that
effectively precludes the utilities from
investing in most weatherization
programs
and this is really contrary to the
purpose of HB 549 from last year
which number one status sought to
establish stable funding for New
Hampshire saves going forward including
weatherization programs and mandated
that the commission employs the same
cost Effectiveness tests that the
commissioner used for previous reviews
of the plans of New Hampshire State's
plans
um as we know weatherization programs
are one of the most cost effective
Energy Efficiency programs
and you know they're very popular too
and so if you want to save a lot of
money on your on your energy bills every
every month you know you should you
should invest in weatherization
um
and you know this this inability to
invest in weatherization programs
especially harms um low-income
households which benefit from some of
the low-income programs under the New
Hampshire safe plans and so
SB 113 would just undo the puc's
interpretation of um you know of the
existing law that was passed last year
and really put us in a place where we
were supposed to be last year which was
you know use the same cost Effectiveness
tests you know that have always been
used by the puc
um you know which was what which was
what the legislature tried to do last
year you know create stable funding
put us back to where we were and so
um by making this small change this one
word change
um the utilities will be able to invest
in these popular and very cost effective
weatherization programs going forward
that can provide significant monthly
reductions and energy costs therefore I
urge you to vote in favor of sp-113 vote
odd to pass and happy to answer any
questions
for Mr krikoff
representative Christian
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question
um so just to kind of restate what you
said in your understanding we've already
sort of litigated the 65 that was all
what we did last year and this is just
clarifying how that 65 you know how that
should be calculated going forward yeah
correct so I'm not here to relitigate
the 65 you know I don't question your
judgment and and putting that into law
last year
but what what this law does is really
you know I think it's intent is to
accomplish the purpose of that
legislation from last year and really
just you know you use the same cost
Effectiveness tests that have always
been used by the puc until this this law
this um order from about a year ago that
you know is a really different different
interpretation of how the puca had
looked at these plans in the past
representative Reynolds has a question
Tom thank you Mr chairman um and just
following up on that
um
is it it's your it's your testimony that
65 was a good number
uh when
it was understood as as you and others
have testified that
everyone everyone understood that that
number applied to was a proper number
when the programs were evaluated on
their annual savings
correct I mean so I you know I don't
know where the 65 number came from
um you know and I you might have to ask
the sponsor of the bill last year
um but
you know the puc had always interpreted
um the savings on an annual basis and so
you know what was new was that this idea
that it needs to be interpreted on this
this lifetime basis and so when looking
at past plans the puc had always
you know the utilities they've
calculated savings based on an annual
basis and that's sort of how the puc
evaluated the savings was on this annual
basis because you know once you look at
this lifetime savings as Mr Le manager
has already testified very well you know
if things don't really add up because
just based on the lifetime you know how
long can these measures last and so
um you know I think the 65 percent you
know that there's a there's a
you know idea that we don't want
electric customers paying for too much
non-electric Energy savings this
representative McGee um stated and so
you know I I think there is some
um
you know there's some rationale to that
and that makes sense but
um
you know what what's different is how
the sort of puc has sort of change that
interpretation from from past plans
thank you
okay seeing no further questions from
the committee I want to thank you for
being here to testify today and next
I'll call on Ray Burke from the New
Hampshire
legal assistance
thank you and good morning
um my name is Ray Burke I'm an attorney
with New Hampshire legal assistants
we're a non-profit Law Firm represent
low-income Granite Staters throughout
the state in various civil legal issues
and we have an energy and utility
Justice project that works on matters
before the puc including the low-income
Energy Efficiency program and so I'm
here today to testify in support of this
bill and and ask that you vote ought to
pass like you've heard from the last
several folks um I'm not gonna I don't
want to repeat much of what was already
covered and that others could testify in
better detail there's a couple things I
think I could add that haven't been
mentioned that may be helpful just very
briefly first as you heard you know the
the low income Energy Efficiency program
is is very important to our low-income
households uh in the past I don't have
updated numbers for you unfortunately
but there has been a wait list for the
program in large part to seek
weatherization services and and the
weather weatherization that's offered
through the program is an important tool
to help low-income customer customers
manage their energy costs
um the two new things I think that I can
uh or maybe they're one thing but from
two different sources is
um New Hampshire's been recognized by uh
both a national entity the American
Council for an energy efficient economy
and from the federal government and how
well we Implement our low-income program
the American Council for an energy
efficient economy and its 2021 progress
report found that New Hampshire was
ranked only second to our neighbor
Vermont in our commitment to the
low-income program and how well we
implement it and as you heard from
others many of the low-income projects
there's a a lot of different there's
different funding sources that are used
namely rate payer-funded Energy
Efficiency program we're talking about
today and the federal weatherization
assistance program and if this bill is
in past it makes it more difficult as I
understand it to coordinate those
programs together and to leverage uh
funding sources from both which has been
a success and so again we urge you to
vote ought to pass so that we can
continue to build on that success and
build on the recognition we've received
and rather than than take a step
backwards um so I'm happy to answer any
questions and thank you again for the
opportunity to testify today
thank you representative Lewis lewicki
has a question for you okay thank you
um it would I'm trying to get an idea of
who these people the people are who
benefit from this because in my
experience very often low-income people
are in rental housing aren't allowed to
change or do anything with the property
and so is this some very small swath of
people who are low income who happen to
own their own properties no uh folks who
are renters are allowed to participate
in both the ratepayer-funded Energy
Efficiency program and the federal
weatherization assistance program the
utilities and the Community Action
agencies uh work with the homeowners to
to do that you do need of course the
homeowner's permission
um so that the renter can't just go and
sign up but but they are eligible if
they meet the requirements and if the
homeowner
um wants to uh you know to work with the
utilities and the Community Action
agencies to do that
follow up
just to clarify I think by saying
homeowner you're talking about landlord
yes okay but and of course if the
low-income household owns the home they
obviously they can participate which I
think you were saying earlier but yes
renters can participate
so you know further questions want to
thank you thank you and we'll Now call
on our last presenter on Senate Bill 113
and that is Sam Evans Brown of clean
energy New Hampshire
welcome back Sam
thank you Mr chairman I will of course
be brief I don't want to repeat anything
that's that's been said um I I wanted to
make two points one is to simply try to
explain the lifetime and annual question
uh uh as if the way I would do it to a
to a
um to my grandmother for instance
um so imagine you have a fridge and you
have some insulation uh the fridge saves
two energies a year the installation
saves two energies a year the
installation lasts 25 years the fridge
lasts 10. uh the fridge will save you 20
energies the installation will save you
50 and that throws off the 65 ratio
question but if you look at them on an
annual basis they both save two so they
meet the test and so that's that's the
basic question that we're trying to to
solve for here the other thing I'd say
uh is that it's really important I think
to remember that the workforce that
pursues these weatherization programs is
incredibly difficult to maintain many
clean energy New Hampshire member
companies are these weatherization
contractors that the type of person who
wants to put on a Tyvek suit and go into
a 140 degree Attic in the summer and
blow insulation into the attic is a
difficult worker to get your hands on
and to hold on to so certainty and and
stability in these programs is very
important I think that if we had not had
the puc order that we had in the fall of
2021 we would have been able to do much
more weatherization coming into the rate
shock that we saw this winter because I
can tell you for a fact that that a lot
of the contractors were very hesitant to
hire new workers because of the
uncertainty that these programs are
facing so that's a simple thing I'd hope
that policymakers would remember
habitat questions or not
questions for Mr Brown
seeing none thank you appreciate it
and with that we're done with Senate
bill 113.
and I'm hopeful that Senator Waters is
going to introduce the next bill
okay interesting
so now we will open a public hearing on
Senate Bill 161 relative to low moderate
income Community solar projects and I'll
call on Senator Waters to testify on
this legislation on behalf of Senator
Perkins quoka who is the Bill's Prime
sponsor Senator Waters thank you thank
you Mr chairman members of the committee
good to see you all uh this morning I'm
here on behalf of Senator Perkins uh
quote to introduce Senate bill
um 61.
and um you know we there's been a lot of
questions about what does this renewable
energy that we're been working on for
the last few years does it really get
down and help over income folks and I
think as we heard in the last bill that
there are a lot of efforts to do that
and one of the very good things that we
did was to um pass the law modern income
Community solar project
a bill a few years back and this bill
attempts to do two things first it it
wants to make sure that
um projects that are housing authorities
and rental properties are able to enter
into Community solar projects that
benefit eligible and moderate income
customers now to do that it does two
things it tries to
rotten out as you'll see in the bowl in
the first line starting line six there
broadened out a little bit the
eligibility
requirements so that we have an
alternative to the federal poverty
guidelines
um and this is useful in a couple of a
couple of reasons that we know what our
median income costs are in New Hampshire
they're pretty darn high and so this
recognizes that people who are under a
certain percentage of the annual median
income are probably challenged getting
some housing and so it would be good for
them if they are in public housing or in
a rental units so supported that these
Community solar projects would be
available to help them reduce their um
their energy energy costs and so we do
this in in two places in the in the bill
um and uh you will see them in the two
sections of the law and this will have
um a you know real uh help
um it'll allow for more loan and modern
income customers to benefit from clean
energy projects we heard a lot from the
Keene Housing Authority about just how
this would uh how this would uh work
there it would open up the grant program
a little more
um broadly to help out low income uh
folks we also heard from the Department
of energy who worked on
on the bill
um that this in some ways was uh also
dealing with a kind of a technical thing
that um let's say you had a lot of
different low-income folks or various
various income levels
um in a building that had just one meter
and so it would be very hard to know
exactly which one which individuals in
that building would qualify at the
federal level but if you have the one
meter and you can look at the Ami for
the residents there then that technical
correction will let them those folks
qualify for the program I probably have
just about reached my knowledge limits
on this bill because I'm here standing
in for Senator Perkins coal Club but I
know there'll be some others who can get
into more of the details on that so it's
not exactly just the technical
correction but I think it takes the
spirit of the program it makes it work a
little better for New Hampshire thank
you Mr chairman
thank you senator for introducing Senate
Bill
161. do we have questions for the
senator representative McGee has one
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question
um
I'm
my question really is uh if you look at
the targeted nature of the bill would
you say that an indirect benefit would
be to help stabilize rental costs as
well as utility costs because I feel
like that might be another piece we
should be aware of
I think it'll help I think if you look
at the overall picture of
um low to moderate income folks who are
facing high energy bills potentially
high-end bills other utility bills and
and whatever else and this kind of
program
can kind of raise their boats in a
certain way by helping deal with some of
these fences I can speak personally to
an experience that the Somersworth
housing project which is in my district
and they did weatherization rehab and a
lot of work there and then brought an
energy Supply through Community solar to
help through the community action
program to help that and you know it's
it's not just that you're helping people
by income you're helping People's Health
too because they're they're living in
cleaner warmer
um better you know better served
buildings and uh able to get some help
on their their energy as well so um this
is what we're hearing from the community
action projects the the housing
authorities that this small change here
will mean they can actually make the
intent of the program work for more of
the residents thank you for your
question thanks
additional questions for the senator
representative lewicki has one thank you
Mr chairman thank you Senator
um
now the radio isn't necessarily a good
source of data but I've been hearing
that rents are up by 50 percent over the
past short period of time and it would
seem that energy costs would be so far
down in the noise that it just not a
concern to most renters would you
disagree or agree with that well thanks
for your question I think what we're
looking at folks who because of that
brutal rental market are able to take
advantage of public housing or other
kinds of rental units and so that this
is a piece of that that puzzle that is
for there for the for those folks in
particular who are included under the
Community
solar and Community energy projects so
um times are tough and this is something
we can do to help
um
additional questions
representative bereshny has one thank
you chairman and thank you for taking my
question uh can you give a sense of how
much larger the program would be with
this language or what some numbers or
just an idea is this going to double the
amount of of possible projects or
all right thank you
um well I I Mr chairman I don't know if
you have someone here from one of the
public housing authorities from who's
going to be coming to testify who might
give you some numbers on that I would I
will just take a question but I will
just say that you know we have overall
limits on how much goes into this
program in general so I'm not sure how
that really all all will play out but
it's an eligibility for for funding that
can potentially help people and uh
and that's what we heard from The
Advocates
representative Nutter has a question
thank you Mr chairman um who's paying
for all this
um
I'm gonna I'm sorry I haven't prepared
morphis I just heard I had to come in I
know the whole I I will look if you look
to that um if you look to RSA 362 F2 you
will find how we do this essentially
what the program allows is for peop
people who want to make investments in
these programs the um well modern income
solar projects that if individuals can
be aggregated
so that there are enough customers that
can off take the development of a of a
solar power project then the financing
numbers work for the entity that wants
to come in and construct such a such a
project and so that's that's basically
how how the products to build investors
do them and then under this program they
can aggregate those little
moderate income customers for solar
and and Mr chairman I think you probably
know better than anyone how to answer
that question but I'm as I said I was
caught a little off guard by having to
come in today with this yeah it's quite
all right yeah I have a question or a
question actually
on lines
seven
and 28 of the bill
there is language that refers to RSA
78-b colon 2 23.
and there is a word
on each of those lines or a phrase on
each of those lines that says as defined
in RSA 78 blah blah blah
I looked at RSA 78 and it
in turn refers to Federal
statute
so would it be better to change the
words as defined to as described
you think that's a reason that would be
a reasonable change
thank you for your question chairman I
think you know oftentimes in Statue we
essentially are deferring a reference to
a federal statute and so since we aren't
defining it but somebody else says that
really does make some sense
okay thank you
further questions for the senator
seeing none I want to thank you senator
for being here
Next Step we're going to call on Griffin
Roberge from the Department of energy
thank you Mr chairman uh members of the
committee again Griffin Roberge from the
Department of energy the department is
neutral to Senate Bill 161 as amended by
the Senate
um for some background uh the general
court passed and Governor sunew signed
into law in 2017 uh Senate Bill 129
which mandated that the department
allocate no less than 15 percent of the
monies in the state's renewable energy
fund annually to the low to moderate
income Community solar program as
defined by Statute this program is
designed to quote benefit low to
moderate income residential customers
including but not limited to the
financing or leveraging of financing for
low to moderate income Community solar
projects and manufactured housing
communities or in in multi-family rental
housing
um
following the passage of this bill the
program was designed through an
extensive stakeholder process that would
meet the statutory requirements and
allow for the review and evaluation of
multiple different uh project models
since the program's creation the
department has typically issued a
competitive requests for proposals or
rfps soliciting project proposals to
fund the Department's latest RFP closed
on March 30th of this year to date the
program has awarded roughly 1.4 million
in grant funding to eight LMI Community
solar projects the program has
successfully helped complete two
projects in Laconia and one in Lebanon
Plymouth Tilton and Dunbarton two
projects are currently underway in
stratum in North Conway the projects
that have been completed and will be
completed include about 164 different
participants and I want to clarify that
participants means households so the
number of individuals who are benefiting
from the program are likely higher
um regarding the bill before you today
uh current statute
Uh current statute onlines
three to twelve everything but the
bolded language
um indic defined what a low to moderate
income Community solar project is that
definition requires that such projects
must directly benefit a group of at
least five residential and use customers
where at least the majority majority uh
you know meaning three of the
residential end user customers are at or
below 300 percent of the federal poverty
guidelines
um as has been mentioned by Senator
Waters in the past there have been
proposals by housing authorities to
apply to this program and receive grant
funding however the department has had
to turn away those proposals because of
the current statutory definition
as you'll see the definition requires uh
benefits to flow directly to residential
end users essentially that means that
those end users need to have their own
meter as has been mentioned by Senator
Waters when it comes to public housing
authorities or other types of housing
projects that can tend to be a Master
Meter just one
um in which case given the current
statutory definition those projects
aren't able to qualify the bolded
language that you see online 6 to 11
means housing authorities and similar
housing projects that have not been
program eligible in the past will be
able to take advantage of this program
if this bill were to become law
section 2 Down Below on line 27 on page
one uh again is just a further add-on
that allows these program dollars to
flow to residents of a public housing
authority or a housing project and that
really concludes my testimony I will
note that
um we are working with chairman Vos on
and please tell me Mr chairman if I'm
treading into the territory I'm not
supposed to
um but we are working on an amendment to
address some technical changes to this
bill including the uh one that the
chairman mentioned to
um Senator Waters when he testified and
with that happy to take any questions
thank you Mr Roberge just for
clarification I did submit some language
to ask OLS and requested that it be
delivered by nine o'clock this morning
and OLS for whatever reason was unable
to
uh accommodate that request so we still
do not have Amendment language but we're
not executing this bill today so
we'll get it when we get it all right
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chair and thank you Mr robes for
being here
um I I did have a question and I think
the chairman referenced
um RSA 78 B2 and I and I looked at that
language
and the in there it's it talks about
um low income low to moderate income
Community solar projects receiving an
additional looks like an additional
um credit
um net metering credit
of 2.5 cents per kilowatt hour
and I guess what I'm trying to
understand is is the purp is that is
that correct and then is the purpose of
this bill to extend that benefit to a
broader Universe of projects sure and
thank you for the question so the 2.5
percent Adder
um was done in 2.5 cents what'd I say
oh sorry cents per kilo forgive me uh
2.5 cents a kilowatt at per kilowatt
hour
um was an add-on in legislation
couple years back I can't remember the
bill but it is meant again to enhance
that benefit for low to moderate income
communities
um it put me up a little bit against a
wall here I can't I can follow back up
with you but it's my understanding that
cert you can qualify for that Adder
under certain conditions you can't
always
um I have to look at the statute again
to kind of unpack that but again the
Genesis of that language is to ensure
that more program benefits flow to those
at the lower end of the economic ladder
follow-up
follow up yeah what I was trying to
understand was if I understand correctly
yep what we're doing is we're changing
the definition of a low to moderate
income Community solar project yep
and if by and by doing that we would
include housing authorities and other oh
yes correct so therefore
without apps in any other change those
projects would then be eligible for this
additional credit uh potentially again
depending on the on the adder
requirements that are in statute again I
just can't remember off the top of my
head but yes correct thank you
representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Roberts for being here
um to follow up on a previous question
uh to the previous testimony do you have
any idea the number of increased
participants that would be eligible for
low moderate income solar projects under
this new sure and thank you for the
question and a follow-up if I can
squeeze it in there where where can we
find uh information about the low
moderate uh solar income so I'm going to
take the first question first uh or the
last question first
um the Department per statute has I
believe issued two different reports
regarding the LMI Community solo program
I think the last one was done sometime
last year I can certainly provide links
to those reports there's also annual
information regarding program successes
um in our annual renewable energy fund
reports and again I can fire that off to
the committee
um
I'm trying to remember your first
question regarding the uh amount the
increased amount of folks who could take
part
um obviously
um public housing authorities uh as they
are defined under statute would be
eligible to take part I don't know
offhand the number of entities who would
be able to take part maybe around maybe
10 or 20 20 20. okay
um I think and there are also public
housing folks here today who might be
able to answer that and again I really
can't predict the futurist to how many
would apply to this program
um but yes I I think there would be a
fair amount of folks would be able to
qualify for it as well
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair and this is
actually a qualification clarification
question on your proposed amendment does
it change anything other than the
terminology defined to described sure
and thank you it's for the chair
actually I'm going to let him answer
that because the amendment language was
submitted by the department sure
um thank you for the question so yeah
um yes our proposed amendment would
alter line seven
and line eight to remove the word
defined to described and the reason
being is that there is no specific
definition in that area of Statute and
78b colon 2 regarding a housing project
but it does list a number of uh
federally funded low-income housing
projects and we'd like to cat I think
the Genesis is to capture those folks
there is another there is another
amendment we are proposing but it's not
to the language outlined in this bill it
seeks to amend some language that was
passed in Senate Bill 270 last year
um that we are working with on the
amendment but that Senate Bill 270 built
on top of this program to require the
department to establish a way to
identify low to moderate income
customers
who could take part in these programs
the department to create that program
needs to establish administrative Rule
and as I think this committee is aware
we are currently in the midst of
revising our administrative rules given
the breakup between the puc and the doe
with this program on top of it it is a
significant administrative burden our
proposed amendment would allow the
department to create
um I guess you could say administrative
rules for this new program by order or
rule to allow us to create a kind of
structure by rule until those rules are
formalized through the administrative
rulemaking process the Genesis of that
is that we don't want you know
necessarily Bad actors taking advantage
of just what's in statute you could have
poor in inadequate applications come
forward we'd like to have some built and
suspenders there for that follow up
follow-up and so will this amendment
come with a fiscal note I I I thank you
for the question I don't don't imagine
it would just because it's really kind
of technical in nature
um yeah that's how I think I'd answer
that thank you representative lewicki
has a question uh thank you Mr chairman
thank you Mr robesch
um and it's perhaps another testifier
might be
more appropriate for this but there
seems that there may be another
constraint involved which is real estate
and it would seem that you know when
you're talking public housing much of it
does not have any place to put solar in
any significant way would you disagree
or agree with that well thank you for
the question I think I I think I might a
little bit push back on that is that
obviously each public housing authority
project is different there's ground
mounted rooftop mounted that type of
thing uh but you know in past projects
the focus has been obviously directing
the benefits and it's obviously the
requirement of the program is directing
the benefits of that Pro of those
projects to low to moderate income
customers themselves
um obviously it's up to the applicant to
determine what what works best whether
rooftop mounted works best or ground
mounting did
um but yeah I would say holistically our
projects tend to be less than 100 KW
um just because it gets in that sweet
spot of where the benefits could maybe
flow down better to low to moderate
income customers
thank you representative munz has
another question thank you Mr chair
um just following up on representative
naughter's question earlier
um
section two of the of the bill
um all that does is make more
uh projects eligible for a fixed pot of
money correct it doesn't expand the
amount of money that's available in the
renewable energy fund that's correct I
would I would submit that the bill
represents an effort to expand
eligibility for a current program in the
department and that program is funded
through the renewable energy fund and I
think we're all aware that that fund is
funded through alternative compliance
payments made through the state's
renewable portfolio standard follow-up
follow-up so there's no additional
expense no
okay seeing no further questions for Mr
roberg we'll Now call on
Josh Meehan
from Keene
and he will tell us who he represents
thank you Mr Meehan from for driving
over from Keene sure thing thank you Mr
chairman thanks everybody on the
committee uh yeah my name is Josh Meehan
I'm executive director of keen housing
we're the city of Keynes public housing
authority
I also serve as the chair of the New
Hampshire Housing Authority
corporation's legislative committee I
live in Keene and I'm speaking in
support of the bill today which allow
organizations like ours to apply for low
moderate income Community solar grants
at our properties where utilities are
included in the rent this is the Master
Meter discussion that's been been going
on
we've applied twice for grant funding
through the community solar program and
twice have been found ineligible because
we provide the electricity to our
residents and it's included in the rent
Keen housing owns and manages almost 600
units of affordable housing in Keene
Swansea Marlborough 43 percent of our
residents are disabled 40 percent of the
households we serve have children
and while over 90 percent of our work
able households are employed the
majority of the households we serve earn
less than 30 percent of area median
income which for a family of four is
around thirty two thousand dollars a
year
some of you may know Keen is a city of
approximately 23 000 people
and as I sit here today we have 2 000
people on our waiting lists
households with kids can wait up to two
years for a two-bedroom apartment that
we own and manage and an elder could
wait up to seven years for an apartment
depending on which department which
development they choose to live in
I like to give that perspective I know
it's not necessarily relevant to the
bill but it it I think it's important
for people to have that perspective
um we receive no state or local funding
for maintaining our aging housing stock
or to develop new housing instead we
rely on a combination of federal
operating subsidy and a patchwork of
federal grants and tax credits none of
which are are sources that we can
control
what we do have some control over though
is our operating costs
every dollar that we save in operating
costs we redeploy to maintain our aging
housing stock to improve resident
services and when we can to develop new
housing that is desperately needed
I think as everyone on this committee is
probably very well aware electricity
rates have gone up significantly
recently and even though we secure our
power through Power purchase agreements
we're still impacted by these Rising
costs
this year so for contacts this year our
operating budget is 2.5 million dollars
and 570 thousand dollars is going to be
our electric bill this year
so it gives you some perspective on the
impact that electricity costs have on us
we've already completed extensive Energy
Efficiency retrofitting and building
envelope tightening throughout our
portfolio and we've actually completed
three solar projects through solar power
purchase agreements
right now we generate about a half a
megawatt altogether but we consume close
to four megawatts a year so we've got a
lot of Gap to make up and we're proud of
the progress that we've made but the
solar ppas as many of you probably know
don't Supply us with free energy it's
energy that's cheaper than if we went to
the default rate but it does increase
those costs do increase over time as
well so this brings me back to the bill
that we're discussing right now if we
could compete for the grants that up
till today we are unable to compete for
that would help us build solar projects
that we owned outright and and if we
couldn't own them out right because we
still need to to get more Capital to do
the projects it would at least reduce
the payback time on the on the solar
power purchase agreements so we could
build more arrays be less leveraged and
move more quickly to reduce our costs
so allowing us access to the low
moderate income Community solar grant
program with directly and positively
impact our ability to maintain our aging
portfolio improve the services we offer
our residents and increase the housing
stock without any new state local or
federal funding this the passage of this
bill wouldn't be a Panacea for the
housing crisis that we're facing in the
state but it certainly would be an
important contribution towards
addressing it so thanks very much for
letting me come and testify today and
I'm happy to answer some of the more
technical Housing Authority like
questions that we're kind of banging
around earlier if you like
yeah our thanks go to you for being here
to testify you have a perspective
different from virtually everybody else
who's been here so we we really do
appreciate your your being here thank
you and representative munz has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for coming in
um you've heard if you you've heard from
a number of us we're trying to
understand the number of
new potential projects that this could
include in the program
the housing number of housing
authorities that's pretty clear but do
you have any sense at all as to what the
number of those other housing projects
would be that are included in the bill
well um it's the answer unfortunately is
um uh opaque and wonky
um so housing authorities when we
develop affordable housing now the the
the federal uh source of funding for
that is something called the low income
housing tax credit program so nobody's
building new public housing but housing
authorities could come in to do solar on
existing public housing and have all the
great benefits that have been discussed
but there are so many different sort of
products if you will for affordable
housing it's really hard to say how many
entities there are that that could
potentially compete for uh for the
grants but that's really what the
language does it allows other affordable
housing providers who here to four have
been cut out from competing for those
grants to be able to compete for them
thank you you're welcome
okay representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um this is a hypothetical question but
should this bill pass how would it
directly benefit your your existing
program well we've as I mentioned
earlier in my testimony we've applied
twice for this grant
um and we would prepare to apply a third
time
and that as I mentioned that would if if
we were successful in our Grant
application it would allow us to move to
our next solar project basically we have
a goal of getting the carbon neutrality
by 2035 as an organization but I should
point out not only because we think it's
important to be to be reducing our
fairly large carbon footprint but
arguably more importantly it saves us a
lot of operating costs and it allows us
to do our mission better
follow up yes thank you
um and you said that you you generate
0.5 megawatts and you consume four so if
you had another uh project in what would
would be the size of it well we
typically do as was mentioned earlier
most of our projects are under a hundred
because there's a there's a tech the way
that the regulations are designed today
that's sort of The Sweet Spot so
generally what we do is relatively small
but but meaningful projects behind the
meters on the roofs of our of our
portfolio and as I mentioned we have 600
units spread across 15 or 16 properties
and we've only put solar on three so far
so we've got a lot of work to do okay
thank you
additional questions
seeing none thank you Mr Sheehan thank
you very much for making the long drive
thank you got it my pleasure thank you
very much next up is Jason quasnick or
Joseph
Mr chairman intending to testifying 167.
my apologies I misread your card I have
so many up here
okay Mr kwasnick is coming up later
so now we have Sam Evans Brown if he's
still Sam is still here yes Good Sam
you're up
still here indeed
um thank you Mr chairman and members of
the committee again for the record I'm
Sam Evans Brown executive director of
clean energy New Hampshire
um just to reiterate what was what has
already been said uh this is a program
that the state has already enacted is
already in statute but is actually
struggling to find projects to give the
funding out to last year there were
there were two projects that applied for
the low to moderate income uh renewable
energy fund grants both were housing
authorities both were denied and this
money was not given out and so we're
really just trying to make an existing
program that is already funded work so
that said I think there's there's a
broader question here that the committee
has has touched on a number of times and
that's the question of how do we make
sure that the programs that the state is
enacting that are trying to reduce the
energy burden for our residents actually
function for folks who do not who are
not who are not themselves homeowners
there's a problem of split incentives if
you are a landlord and you do not pay
the the energy bills of your 10 you have
no incentive to invest in Energy
Efficiency or any sort of on-site
generation to try to reduce the bills
for your tenant because that's only
costs for you however if you do as the
housing authorities do and you you pay
the energy bills for your tenants that
then means that you become ineligible
for many of the the types of incentives
that the state makes available to reduce
energy spending and that is that is a
that is a problem that I would hope that
policymakers would take very seriously
and this is just a modest step in the
direction of trying to trying to again
reduce energy burden for New Hampshire's
residents
thank you questions for Mr Evans Brown
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chair and thank you uh you you
just mentioned something that kind of
raised it an interesting question in my
mind so if a if if if there is a a
situation where a group of low-income
um
tenants live in a building owned by a a
landlord
um
if they want to try to participate in
this program
or a program that would reduce their and
they pay their own utility bills and
they want to participate in a program to
reduce their utility bills does this
does this program a lot you know allow
that
uh or is there other language that needs
to be added to facilitate that so so
sort of depends on the ownership
structure right so if if they are simply
a group of of low-income residents that
are taking that you know renting from
Market housing and it's not um it's not
participating in any sort of program for
low-income folks that group of tenants
would have to work with their landlord
to and theoretically with some sort of
entity that could submit the application
on their behalf in order to put in a a
Grant application to this competitive
program which would be pretty
complicated Endeavor which I think tells
you why we don't see many of those
applications
um it's it's precisely this problem that
led clean energy New Hampshire to work
on Senate Bill 270 last year which was
passed on a bipartisan basis through
this body which which automatically
assigns uh off takers for for low-income
solar projects from the roles of folks
who are already participating in the
electric assistance program where there
there are so many barriers that are in
place you know I think we have to get
creative about how we work to eliminate
those barriers so I think the answer is
to your question is sort of depends on
who owns the building
um but the answer might in most cases be
no which I think uh suggests that there
there's still other policies that the
legislature could consider in terms of
how do you eliminate barriers to the
programs that that we've enacted to try
to reduce energy burden
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chair so in follow-up to
representative Munn's question
um can we clarify that the testimony
that we heard from the Keen Housing
Authority is really who it's targeted at
is existing housing authorities who
would very much like to be able to lower
their electric bills for their tenants
and for themselves for their operating
costs uh so it's it's targeted that is
right and and uh and initially so uh we
have worked extensively with the
Department of energy on drafting this
language along with Mr Meehan from the
Housing Authority initially this bill
was much much simpler in its language uh
but the feedback was that uh that very
simple language did not recognize the
reality of how low-income and affordable
housing is is built and managed by the
housing authorities and as you have as
you could have heard uh you know I got
essentially a master seminar from Mr
Meehan and exactly how the housing
authorities work uh and it's it's
immensely complex which is why the bill
has to be as complicated as it as it is
thank you
additional questions
seeing none thank you Mr Sam Evans Brown
and next we'll call on Dan weeks to give
us the
industry perspective on this legislation
and I'm I assume you'll assume you're uh
introduce your guest to us sidekick here
um was not able to go to school today
and mom has to teach so I hope you don't
mind me having some company here of
course not thank you chairman Vos and
members of the committee my name is Dan
weeks vice president at revision energy
um glad to be with you from Nashua this
morning with my trusty sidekick
um very briefly we are a construction
company employee owned we do solar and
various Clean Energy Solutions
um and I'm one of 400 co-owners most of
my fellow employees are on roofs or in
basements or attics today it's a
beautiful day to be installing clean
energy in New Hampshire and we're proud
to count uh electricians apprentices
plumbers Etc among our co-owners
um
very grateful for the opportunity to
testify in support of SB 161 because I
think it goes to what has been an
important bright spot in New Hampshire's
clean energy policy over the last
several years in identifying and seeking
to prioritize the needs of lower income
granted Staters to participate in the
clean energy transition and to enjoy the
cost-saving benefits that result
uh I think we are probably all aware
that unfortunately for most of the last
several decades since solar has been a
solution available to families it's been
mostly higher income
folks who have been able to take
advantage in far too few of those who
who get the benefits and cost savings
from solar are folks on low incomes and
so I want to First appreciate the way in
which this legislature and Governor snow
have prioritized this important need of
expanding access to these Solutions and
support this particular fix to do what I
think all parties intended in the
original legislation setting out our LMI
programs and just make it more effective
uh for revision as an employee-owned B
Corporation expanding access to solar is
core to our mission yet I'm sorry to say
that of the roughly 15 000 installations
we've completed only a few hundred have
been for very low income folks here in
New Hampshire and in neighboring states
where we work and we really want to
change that for every year in which the
New Hampshire Department of energy
formerly puc Grant programs have been
available through the renewable energy
fund we have applied we've worked with
resident owned communities mobile home
communities we've worked with Keen
housing and other housing authorities
throughout the state and it has been I
think the to the disappointment of
everybody involved that multiple
otherwise good projects have just not
been able to go forward
particularly because these projects
generally with housing authorities keen
and others serve the lowest income
granted Staters out there
and it is for multiple good reasons that
I think you've already heard that their
bills tend to be paid directly by the
Housing Authority but again the
unintended consequence has been that
those individuals cannot participate
I would simply stress that what we're
talking about here is not increasing the
funding available although that might be
nice we're simply talking about
expanding the ability of more entities
particularly those serving again the
lowest income granted stators to compete
for that funding and to make it
therefore more inclusive so I don't
imagine there would be any increase in
in state obligations here it would again
simply make the program more competitive
as well as more inclusive of the lowest
income folks
um
I'll just conclude in saying that again
these programs set very exciting
potential to do what I believe all
parties intend making solar more
accessible to folks and with modest
fixes I am hopeful that particularly
these types of projects which tend to be
inherently more expensive putting solar
on smaller rooftops often older roofs
which may need to be replaced which may
need structural reinforcements that is
challenging and that's part of the
reason why only a fraction of the total
solar installed directly serves low
income folks this bill will help again
expand who can benefit so thank you very
much happy to take any questions
thank you for being here and giving us
the industry perspective is there any
questions for Mr weeks
representative Reynolds has one
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Dan
for being here today again
um would you characterize this
legislation this bill as finally
aligning
the policy
the intent of the policy to direct solar
the benefits of solar to those who could
most benefit from it with the rules of
of implementation of the program
thank you representative Reynolds I
think that's right
um I recall in the deliberations around
SB 165 I think it was three years ago
creating the Illinois programs that
there was a clear intent from leaders on
both sides to achieve this end and I
think it was an unintended consequence
of the way in which
residential end user customer was
interpreted we were involved in detailed
discussions with the Department of
energy around exactly what that meant
and it was I think not intended by
anybody that that would exclude these
lowest income folks who are indeed
energy customers of the utilities it
just happens that the bills are not in
their name they're in the name of the
public housing authority
thank you
representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
weeks for being here thanks to your
sidekick
this is a question that's been asked
previous uh testifiers and maybe your
your business has an idea of how many
additional uh project applicants could
possibly come out of this at legislation
beyond the 20 public housing authorities
that we know about
thank you representative Kaplan
I think it as has been stated previously
it is the public housing authorities who
would be most directly affected by this
and would therefore be able to compete
in a way they have not today
I have not done a detailed assessment of
all the low-income housing in the state
to know whether there's only a small or
more significant amount of other
affordable housing developments in which
electric bills are paid centrally by the
provider of housing as opposed to by the
end user customers I believe it is
pretty unique to to these public housing
authorities
and again I would just reiterate that
this bill does not affect the funding
levels it simply affects who can compete
for those available funds and I think
helps us to avoid a situation as was
mentioned last year where multiple
applications were submitted but none
were deemed eligible and so for an
entire year none of these low-income
participants could benefit
okay seeing no further questions from
the committee I want to thank you for
being here and I'm going to close the
public hearing on Senate bill 161.
now we will open a public hearing on
Senate Bill 166 and I'll call Senator
David Waters the prime sponsor of this
legislation to introduce it to US
senator Waters
and I would remind anybody who wants to
testify on this bill to submit a pink
card please
good morning again and thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee
Senator David Waters District 4 to
introduce Senate Bill 166 relative to
grid modernization and I I just want to
thank the doe the utilities
um lots of folks here and in the Senate
who have helped work on this bill I
think because we have a shared
recognition that we really do have to
move forward on grid modernization and
while the bill may not be perfect may
not cover everything I think we have a
pretty good framework here for for your
consideration and perhaps an improvement
um I'd like to say just a few things
about you know what grid modernization
is about and what what it can do and
then I'll get into the details of the
bill
um I think first and foremost we need to
modernize the grid to increase
competition
uh it'll get a free market mechanisms
into energy
also it is going to help provide for a
more stable and reliable grid because
we're going to manage uh demand and the
resources available to us much much
better
um I think also New Hampshire has a
great potential for grid modernization
and for it to be a tool to help us lower
energy car costs and to introduce Market
based pricing
um I think also we need to get our grid
ready for the kinds of projects that are
coming down the pike it's not just the
the solar and other things but um you
know we're looking at offshore wind uh
the auctions are next summer which is
like tomorrow in terms of that industry
about 3.2 gigawatts are going to be
developed out in the Gulf of Maine we've
got to onshore that power and make sure
it gets at a low cost to our um
communities and
um this is why is oh New England has
Dean grid modernization as necessary
throughout the states
um both to improve efficiency but also
to combat higher
prices and then also
you know I will get to the 10-year
energy plan and other plans uh put
forward by the department of energy
where they identify good modernizations
one of the really important things in
New Hampshire uh can do to get
market-based um reforms and lower the
cost of energy I'll say additionally too
that the six New England Governors
including obviously Governor sununu were
in a meeting with uh Isa New England and
folks and uh are we're discussing I had
a presentation about doing a the New
England states Governor's endorsing a
plan to come together to work on grid
modernization as a as a group and um
you'll see a little bit about that in
167 but I think that's a something that
New England Governors are recognizing
that this is something that all the
states need to do and can do it perhaps
more cheaply
um together so the bill um it it it it
tries to introduce market-based uh
improvements and you'll see a lot in the
bill on that uh this is meant to um you
know provide improvements in pricing to
increase resources and competition
uh it's also designed to lower energy
costs through a variety of means of grid
modernization
it also helps us in the state to
establish the technical expertise we're
going to need in the doe and for the puc
um and I think those those goals you'll
see here as well so if we could turn to
the first page the bill um the findings
in some ways lays out what I've just
described especially starting on line
eight
um the 10-year energy strategy looking
for market-based mechanisms for
achieving costs of effective energy
and the statement on lines 1011 here
from that energy plan the New Hampshire
should seek the Foster environment where
new
and emerging Technologies can flourish
by the value they may bring to the
market and to encourage Market selection
of cost-effective energy resources so
that really is what a lot of this bill
is about and it does it through a few a
few things it does it through
distributed energy resources
distributor generation distributed
storage and these methods can help
reduce and stabilize costs for uh rate
rate payers and in a sense this also
goes all the way back to the 1990s when
we did the restructuring under 374 and
one of the goals of 374 in 1996 was to
make sure that we get to the point where
we have a competitive markets and I hope
this bill can move us forward
um towards that I'd like to turn if I
could
um page three of the bill now Mr
chairman
and um here's where you get the
definitions which lay out the bigger
picture items that I have been
mentioning
um and so I think we learned
particularly this winner about demand
response that if we end up in the
situation where we have uh very high
demand and pushing up Energy prices to
astronomical levels can we have methods
to manage demand response and so that's
part of what a modernized grid
can do
um then also uh it has some definitions
to look at distributive storage I think
storage
is going to be an increasing component
of grid modernization and demand
response management do note if you would
on lines 23 following that I'm trying to
accomplish here uh an integration of of
grid elect integrated electric vehicle
the car companies are bringing these
forward where there's software package
within the car so that you can charge
you can charge up the battery but the
utilities could also pull the power out
to help deal with spikes and uh if I
think rather conservative projection
that we're going to have about 60 000
electric cars in the state by 2030
um that this this if you aggregate all
those batteries that can really do
something for us to have a big storage
system that can help us deal with price
bucks you may have noticed in the energy
crisis we had this winter with the cold
temperatures that uh some places where
parking electric bus school buses out in
front of emergency medical facilities to
provide them with the power that they
need and we are we have grants in place
and we are going to be getting some
electric buses in the state so this is a
capacity there and I think we had to
kind of update some places in statute to
make sure that this new kind of capacity
gets included in Grid modernization
a lot of where the rubber hits the road
on this bill starts at the bottom of
page three
um with the metering and you'll see in
this section here and onto the top of
the next page it gets that kind of two
things what kind of metering do we need
to have so this can get done so we can
get accurate price signals added
intervals that are small enough so that
people can understand how to you know
how to enter a competitive market with
the power that they are they are
producing had a lot of discussion with
utilities about the Amis the new
metering they cost something
there's concerns about how how these
would be rolled out whether it be pilot
programs or whatever but everybody
recognizes that we've got to get to this
Advanced metering
not only so the utilities know right
what power is being supplied and how
it's being metered but then can that
information as you'll see in the bottom
of this page can that information be
provided to the local the ders that
generators so that they understand they
have the price signal to know when to
put Power into the market uh when to
when to take it out
then on the top of page four it gets the
other side of that okay well how do we
deal with in Grid modernization the
potential sources that are going to help
us do this and so that's why
5678 we get into the various sources
storage and then interconnection issues
as well
so I know those are kind of technical
things but you see how the bill the bill
kind of builds the principles and then
here are the technical errors that need
to be addressed if I may Mr chairman
I'll go back to page um two
and uh the establishment of a grid
modernization Advisory Group
the bill takes the strategy of
recognizing that there's some real work
to be done on some of the technical
issues that I have described and so we
need a group to work on that because at
this point in time it's not really clear
just exactly what to do in statute
so it was very very useful to have this
group have certain duties and to be able
to work on certain things that everybody
agrees who were on this group need to be
worked on and they should do it together
then the other parts of the bill are
some things that we think could be done
now and I'll get to those in a moment
but the screen Advisory Group you'll see
who's on it
um and you know all these folks have
been contacted and seemed appropriate
through discussions with doe and others
that these are the ones who ought to be
there working on um
these issues and uh then you've got the
duties starting on line 19.
um you know just to make sure under the
original 1996 uh restructuring
organization under the 374 F2 that the
principles of grid modernization are
following from those statutory
requirements
um to look at what we need to do about
transactive energy and advanced metering
infrastructure because that's something
that's going to be a challenge for
utilities but we've got to figure out a
way to do that some other states are
taking their approaches let's take a
look at what's going to work for New
Hampshire how to do the settlement or
Price signals that it'll work in a
modernized grid and then
um how is it have an appropriate system
where customer and distributed energy
resources have access to temporal price
signals so they can get into this
competitive market
and then one I think particularly
important issue starting on line 28
um interconnection interconnection and
this is an important issue for being
able to bring new resources onto the
grid
you may have heard from your districts
concerns about internet connection costs
um Dover I'll give you one example they
wanted to build a solar project out at
the County Farm
and that would help you know reduce
costs greatly for city of Dover and for
the County Farm Complex as well
so the nearest interconnection point is
over in Madbury
about a mile and a half away and so they
get a price to be a couple million
dollars for the interconnection
now that suddenly changes the numbers
here for the price of the project and
for the investors who are interested in
it
and the problem that comes from that too
is that okay so the first person the
first person to come forward pays the
whole Freight
but then there might be five or six
other projects that come in behind it
so shouldn't we look at a mechanism
whereby those subsequent folks could
help
offset or return some of the costs the
original investor the model I put
together here that the committee would
look at
is what I'd worked on with Senator
boutin uh when we had the same issue
around mall development or commercial
industrial property development that if
the first person came in and paid for
you know the water sewer and
infrastructure and then they built their
Factory or their you know or their
commercial building and then five or six
other people come in so shouldn't they
be able to get some of their original
investment back and you know so Senator
boat and I did that with that and I
thought well that's the model we ought
to look at
um so that's why there's an actual a
little bit of a hurry update Say by
September 1st 2024 let us know
um you know what the utilities and
others think can work on this and we got
pretty far down the road actually trying
to develop a mechanism where that could
work and put it in the Statue but didn't
quite get there so that that one is uh
going to help there bottom of the page
two um this is something that's come up
quite a bit on grid modernization that
we need some technical expertise there
was some discussion about whether to put
um the Consulting for this in the Office
of Consumer Advocate it was thought no
it's better to put it in the department
of energy
um and that is a recoverable cost so
there's no physical note on that
um I think you're going to hear from
Department of energy that they think
there needs to be a little a little
tweak here about how that consultant
gets paid um but that's that's why that
is there and it's very clear we need
this technical expertise going
uh go going forward
um so let's turn if we could then
towards the end of the bill on page four
and here's where uh
we get into some things that we thought
could be done now
um
so uh I mentioned the interconnection so
here's on the middle of page four to put
in statute that the interconnection
requirements that group is going to work
on should be consistent with what we've
already said about that under 378
um 37 under our policy that
interconnection standards are something
that needs to be accomplished then
you'll see a little bit before there's a
couple of places here where we in our
definition of storage in the next couple
Pages we get those grid integrated
electric vehicles included in a
definition so technically that can work
out
um then um you're going to hear a lot
more about this from doe and from
um Cliff below but both of them again I
want to thank for their help on this
bill
um what about the pilot projects now
we've approved some of these uh and
we're hearing from the folks who are
developing them that we didn't quite get
it right in terms of the size of these
and who doesn't so you're going to hear
about some potential adjustments here
um doe has some new ideas about it Cliff
Bo has some ideas I know there's a lot
of expertise on this committee and I
think that we probably do to do need to
make some adjustments here but I think
it's something you're going to be
clearly working on about how many of
these pilots and what size they are and
why we might need to um
pay some attention to it and do note on
page five that um because there are
um there's there is some something
before the puc that just want to
acknowledge that they are going to have
some guidance in so that whatever is
proposed here about these Pilots will be
in accordance with the guidance the POC
is
um is is bringing forward
um I think the rest of it is largely
um technical I do want to mention at the
very end here
um lines 23 to 27 working with the
assistant commissioner
Mark Sanborn you know after that meeting
of the governors
um where they said yeah we've got to
work together on um uh on grid for
offshore wind so I we thought that it
would be um useful to put into statute
that are
um that
what we what we do in the office of
offshore wind is to take on this
responsibility of working with the other
states and working with the Bureau of
ocean Energy Management on these plants
we need a place in the government where
these plans get centralized and worked
on so that our governor can participate
with the other other states uh
um there so that that's why this is uh
was added on into the bill because it
seemed like a convenient place to to do
that and there is some funding in the
budget as I understand that came out of
the house that helps this office out a
bit so I will
stop there Mr chairman and after this
little blizzard of details and we got to
take any questions
well thank you that was a blizzard
I suppose water should say it was a
flood but whatever
hopefully we will be able to endure it
all
I do have one question at the risk of
stealing the Thunder of Representative
Wendy Thomas
the fiscal note
attached to this bill basically says
nothing could you explain to us how
fiscal notes work in the Senate are they
different from how they work in the
house where would we find the fiscal
note for example have you looked at it
Etc
um it's done just the same way it's done
for the house
um exactly the same way and uh I think
that the way this this bill it was
amended quite a bit so I think that it
was difficult as always for the
um for the budget office to kind of
catch up with it but as I look at this
I'm not sure except for the um the
little piece about the offshore wind
office
um which is covered in the budget
there's no appropriation here just says
that's their responsibility paying for
it is is in the budget
um and then um the other potential cost
is for that consultant
but that's a recoverable cost the DOA
has that authority to do that as it's
outlined here
so the group is going to get together so
you know I mean is there cost to the
group getting together I you know but
otherwise I'm not I'm not entirely sure
that there is much of a physical impact
um that's that is attributed to any of
the kind of particular things in here
okay thank you
since you mentioned the Advisory Group
and how it's going to get to itself
together it's so on and so forth
I'd like you to speak a little bit more
about why an Advisory Group is needed I
mean the department of energy
must have staff and of course I'll ask
them this question when they testify but
they must have resources that they can
apply to
determining
grid modernization needs
why do they need an Advisory Group and
wouldn't this Advisory Group because
it's comprised of a bunch of people who
have other jobs
have difficulty getting together and
meeting and coming up with concrete
recommendations for the Department well
thanks for the questions and I mean it
really is is kind of in two parts and I
think the first part is that
I think the department of energy will
tell you that the the capacity for
looking at all these areas is perhaps
best served by having the folks who you
know as boots are on the ground I mean
you know if you want to talk about
metering and you want to talk about
um interconnection points and so forth
having the utilities that are facing
that and then the folks who are trying
to get such things done at the table
with you is a lot more probably the best
way to go and the folks a lot of
discussion around this a lot of
discussion with the department and with
these these participants who are saying
we we think this is the best way to get
it done there's a lot of issues here but
we can get together and we can we can
work through them as as a group and I
think it makes some I think it makes
some sense you know sometimes we set up
legislative commissions which have these
kinds of people on it but then we have
to have you know a whole lot of
legislators now and I thought that you
know yes Mr chairman it is their job to
do these kinds of things but I think
that through a partnership through a
working group like this that can be
there
um you know as new issues emerge and can
and can kind of work work with work with
each other that that that and they're
going to have the expertise of that kind
consultant
that is in here too and that that's kind
of a key to helping make this this work
for everybody involved
okay great thank you additional
questions representative Doug Thomas has
one thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question
um uh realizing that your emphasis was
now all right but I my question involves
the fact that you in your in your
dissertation you you mentioned the term
clean energy it does not appear in this
in this bill here but um then I read
down on page three on the grid
modernization line 27 uh what you what
you talk about what grid modernization
means my question is realizing that the
time is not now but sometime in the
future uh not too distant future
does this bill would this bill and this
definition here also apply eventually to
small-scale nuclear energy is this can
this be applied the same way and mean
the same way and and and and and if so
uh is there room somewhere in this bill
there where that could be mentioned at
least as part of grid marginalization
um yes and I thank you for mentioning
that because I I think that is just a
crucial inclusion because that is that's
in that potentially can be an important
uh part of future reliable energy
um sources and um
I think that uh it might be useful I
mean I have in that that working group
you know and other issues and other
sources and I think if I think that
could be explicitly put in and that
could be
um quite helpful to have there because I
do think that the grid modernization
definition certainly incorporates these
kinds of new technologies I mean that's
why the findings new technologies new
technologies we've gotta we've got to be
aware of them and understand what good
modernization and particularly what kind
of advanced metering
the bottom line of this bill is what can
help us avoid the kind of demand spikes
so that we're not seeing our costs
escalate in the state and then also how
is it that we can make sure that folks
who want to bring these new sources can
get the appropriate price signals so
they can be a competitive market there
which will lower cost so yes oh yeah all
right thank you so so any should any
Amendment come as a result of this bill
here uh you'd be amenable to that idea
being added as well thanks sir I would
say that you could you could um you know
have include you know under the
definition here of good modernization
say inclusive of
and I think also under that working
group that I think it's kind of
implicitly that anything comes along you
got to talk about it but if you want to
make it a little more explicit that you
want to mention mention that kind of as
a placeholder
it's a that seems like a good idea
let's keep the Thomas train running and
call on representative Wendy Thomas
thank you very much Mr chair
um and thank you senator for being here
um with regard to The Advisory Group
I've noticed there's no representative
from the house or the Senate um however
they do do an annual report that is
presented to the house and the Senate
you're comfortable with having no
participant involved well um thanks for
your question but let us let me remind
the committee that we passed the bill
last year that says that any commission
or committee that's set up with
legislators has to have a majority of
legislators so do the math and
commentary people on this thing and
you're going to have to load it up with
the legislators who every two years May
or not be here so that's why I
structured into it the the group and the
reporting so so follow up follow up so
um so that's the definition of Advisory
Group as opposed to commission okay
thank you yeah I mean advisor group is
whatever you want to make it into it
just that the important thing it's not a
it's not a commission because then that
provision of Statute kicks in
representative Christian has a question
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question um I also have a question
related to the
um
advisory committee so it seems like it's
very focused on
you know right now the issues that we're
facing and kind of needing to create a
transformation in our Energy System
um but there's no sort of like
expiration date on the committee do you
foresee this you know continuing and the
grid really continuing to evolve
substantially or um
well thanks for the question you know
and don't don't you think we're going to
need this I mean I I just think about
the last few years I mean who who would
have thought of offshore wind right who
would have thought of really commercial
viable solar I mean my goodness 10 years
ago the panels are so expensive right
um and in electric vehicles you know and
and the and the capacity as well to have
grinted grid integration where these
these flows can go both ways and and
storage who thought of electrical
storage you know we had a battery in
your car that was your electrical
storage right so um I am sure and as
representative Thomas mentioned there
there are going to be news sources and
then the technology in these in these
areas are developing very fast about
what we can do on on metering and
distributing distributed energy
resources so I I think there's gonna be
work to do
um for this and and I I to say
personally
my feelings about this I want to I want
New Hampshire to be competitive I want
low energy costs right and I I think I
just want to make sure that we are ready
to be nimble and can have in statute the
kinds of tools that are needed so we can
you know not be at the mercy of energy
spikes and foreign energy sources and
all that and I think I think grid
modernization is is gonna you know get
get us back in charge of our of our
energy in a way that's going to save
money for us
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question It just
strikes me as a as a program manager
myself that this is a great way to get
at
um you know we don't have a plan that
we're following but we know that grid
modernization is something that we have
to understand and so our tendency has
been to
um put up bills that we think are good
you know Target these things
individually uh and try and see if we
can move those individual bills but not
in an overall context for what we're
doing and I think I like this bill
because it lays out the different
um building blocks if you will that have
to be considered so that there is there
a question here having the conversation
so yeah there is
um so my question is uh
do you see this taking the place of all
of those uh individual efforts and I'll
give you a specific example we had an uh
an EV bill that we I'm sorry smart meter
bill that went through our committee
this year trying to get at
whether we could have optional meters
available through the utilities so
people could start helping to convert a
system that might be expensive to do as
a mandate so we we are I think
biting at the heels of the things in
this bill but this bill gives us a
framework so
um can you just speak to whether that's
the goal of the bill uh is to set us on
a framework where we actually have some
answers to these questions
thank you and um I think that really
what it I hope it does is set up a
process that we can get to something or
work for New Hampshire the example you
mentioned
I worked a lot on that potentially in
here and then realized that I don't
think it's possible yet to make a plan
for New Hampshire to have the utilities
be able to move forward on the the Ami
um there are a lot of reasons for that
part of its costs if you go down to
Massachusetts the utilities are getting
about 100 million dollars from the state
to do the the metering well we're not
doing that we're not gonna
so what can work for New Hampshire and
um I think everybody knows we've got to
do it right utilities say yeah we've got
to do it but we've got to find out a way
that will work for us and I and I think
that there are many things like that
that we have been beating our heads
against and trying to take little pieces
of it and get it done and I I just think
that well what you have when you have
problems like that you get people
together you work with utilities and the
doe and the puc and figure out what can
work for New Hampshire so I think
there's an opportunity there then you
know rather than end up with piecemeal
or frustration to to have a rational
plan that can emerge from this group
that we legislators can then figure out
how to how to make into policy in Mr
chair I have one more follow-up
follow-up
um in section three on page one uh you
had referred to several points for
um that came out of the 10-year energy
strategy the state energy strategy but
one of the ones that you
stop short on which I would like you to
comment on would be on line 13 goal
eight generate in-state economic
activity without Reliance on permanent
long-term subsidization of energy we
have a lot of conversations on this uh
committee about subsidies so could you
state specifically why that one's in
there yeah thank you I think it's an
important principle yeah I mean I like
research and development I like startup
I like you know we we have traditionally
provided all kinds of federal subsidies
for certain kinds of energy sources and
uh you know I I don't think there's any
appetite for permanent subsidies or for
cost shifting or anything so this is I
think that's an important principle I
think it's a New Hampshire principle too
let me just mention one other thing too
about about this well I think this bill
is Timely
um the IRA bill has 3.1 million dollars
for each state that applies to do an
action plan
on energy and climate things and doesn't
require you to any mandates or anything
like that it says you you can get 3.1
million dollars and uh we were you know
103600 ply we're applying now and uh
it's pretty straightforward application
we should get that money pretty soon uh
assistant commissioner Sanborn is
heading that up on the governor's behalf
so we're going to have 3.1 million
dollars for for people to come in and
help us to do
planning as well there's a little money
in here too so I think we have a context
where we're going to have some real
oomph around figuring out
just that you know what what can work
for New Hampshire and how do we get it
done for our system so I'm I'm very I'm
actually I'm very optimistic I think it
was a good partnership now with the with
the governor utilities all of us to to
get at some of these big problems that
we've been you know we've been working
on for several years
representative muttons has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you Senator
again for being here
um as as you as you know
um citing for major energy projects has
been a challenge has been in it and
given that does it make sense to have
somebody from Des on the work group
um thank you for that question I think
we're gonna I I think appropriately we
are going to be handling site
sighting in the structures that we
already have and this really is is not
about citing per se it's about these
grid issues and I'm not sure the Des
would really want to see it at this
table
representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you senator
for being here
um I just first want to Echo uh
representative McGee's commendations for
the you know the scope of this bill I
think it's it's a it's going to be a
great thing for the state to take on uh
in in lieu of the at you know because of
the absence of an overall strategy that
something like this is very useful uh my
question is how does grid modernization
and transformative pricing signals Etc
how does that impact on our net metering
program do you have an idea of how that
would work
thanks for the question and I would
think that it potentially could make it
more efficient
um because we will have
you know this doesn't address that in
directly
um because that has its own regulatory
framework but if we're looking at you
know how is it that we're going to have
distributive energy sources whether
under imaginary programs or not
um how are we going to have them more
effectively manage to help reduce costs
for all of us
um so I don't know if it's an answer to
your question but that's you know this
is not particularly directed towards
that it's directed towards the kind of
but you don't see it having an impact at
all on net metering
um I think that anything that helps them
improve the time increments and the
price signaling
um especially as you think about
some of the net metering entities or the
um
Community power Coalition might start
looking into storage
uh capacities as a way of dealing with
demand response and so on it could be
related to that sure
yeah
okay seeing no more questions for
Senator Waters we'll move on now and
thank you thank you very much
introducing the legislation we'll move
on now to the Department of energy and
Griffin Roberge will give us the
Department's uh perspective
thank you Mr chairman uh members of the
committee uh again Griffin Ro bush from
the Department of energy uh neutral to
Senate Bill 166 as amended by the Senate
um I think Senate Waters gave a good
overview as to what the Genesis of this
bill is
um
I think my testimony today I'm going to
outline a few observations that the
department has with uh has of the bill
but I do want to note immediately from
the outset that we are still reviewing
um the statutory changes outlined in
this bill and we may have additional
observations as time goes on
um what I'm what I have to offer today
are just some initial observations again
it's nowhere near final I would submit
um in section two of the bill as I
believe Senator Waters mentioned uh the
bottom of page two
line 34
to assist the grid modernization
advisory committee the department May
obtain the services of a consultant for
technical support
for Department of energy staff the
consumer Advocate and the grid
modernization Advisory Group it then
goes on to say that the department of
energy shall charge a special assessment
for any such amounts for this consultant
against any utility participating in The
Advisory Group and shall provide for the
timely recovery of such amounts for the
affected utility
the department has uh you know I think
respectfully can certainly charge
special assessment costs but it cannot
recover those costs that is a duty of
the Public Utilities Commission if this
bill is to move forward we would suggest
inserting the Public Utilities
Commission on page three
line one
between and and shall
so the puc I'm sorry the department
would be able to charge the special
assessment but the recovery of costs
would come through uh the puc
um moving on to page four
um we did want to note some technical
concerns with the way that the bill is
currently written if you look on page
four line six
it references RSA 378 colon 37 the New
Hampshire's energy policy that statute
was repealed under house bill 281 has
passed by this body should both bills
make their way into law there could
potentially be a conflict so I want to
flag that for the committee's
consideration
same concerns extend down to page four
line 20 again makes another reference to
RSA 37
378 colon 37 again that was repealed
under house bill 281. additionally with
our uh with section four the department
feels that that whole section would be
better removed outright the reason being
is that it makes reference to
interconnection requirements and
procedures the department does have an
open investigatory proceeding on uh
interconnection standards per Senate
Bill 262 from last year we prefer to let
that process play out
um before making sizable changes such as
this in section four
um section six
um regarding pilot programs under the
Lipa statute
um this you may recall uh for those who
are around was passed with Senate Bill
321 from last year that would create
these Pilots under the Lepa statute the
department has uh some concerns with
page four line 29 where it eliminates
the current language no more than one
pilot shall be permitted for any utility
the department would submit that the
purpose of a pro of a pilot program is
to undertake an activity as a test or a
trial to help understand how
it would be beneficial as the pr as the
as the program builds out
um in our respectful opinion eliminating
that language does not it's no longer a
pilot anymore you can just have any
number of projects you want up to the
proposed five megawatt cap we would uh
encourage the committee to retain the
language on page four line 29
um and if so that would also necessitate
further changes in section seven
uh which is again further down on page
four lines 35 and 36 that change could
be removed
and then finally on page five
lines five to six uh five to seven
should be removed as well with a period
right after resolved on line five I
realized that that was a lot of sorting
through lines pages and everything like
that that really concludes the
Department's immediate
um observations with the bill I'm happy
to take any questions but again as I
mentioned uh still reviewing the bill in
its entirety
okay thank you for uh your perspective
questions from the committee let's go to
representative cretian first
chair thank you for taking my question
um just wanted to follow up on that the
reasoning for
um basically keeping utilities
prohibited from participating in one or
more pilots wouldn't that
I guess can't you imagine a situation
where a utility might want to try
different Technologies or or be
participating in Pilots for for sort of
different angles on this why would it
make sense to make them finish one
before starting another sure and thank
you for the question so as part of
Senate Bill 321 before these Pilots can
it all be conducted under uh section six
uh there is a major question of some
jurisdictional issues between State
jurisdiction ISO uh jurisdiction that is
to be sorted out through a proceeding at
the Public Utilities Commission before
any of these Pilots can take place
following the resolution of those
jurisdictional issues and whether or not
these Pilots could take place again the
purpose of a pilot program is to engage
in the test trial to see how it would
work
um you know on a larger scale you see
that in different proceedings before the
puc such as battery storage and that
type of thing
um before even One Pilot pro project is
being proposed we're already talking
about removing the cap and allowing just
and allowing just any amount of projects
within a utility territory I think we
would prefer to let the pilot play out
first to see how it works and then
should there be success in the
legislature wants to amend that to you
know remove that language on the pilot
the certain uh certainly legislation in
the future can be brought forward to do
that but at this time again there are
many steps that should take place before
we reach that hurdle
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chair
um Senator Waters mentioned that there
is
um
about 3.1 million dollars coming to the
state through the IRA
um could that money be used to pay the
consultant
rather than trying to recover it from
utilities and therefore the customers
sure and thank you for the question um
it's a good question it's not when I
have an answer to it's just because that
is a funding opportunity coming down
through an Environmental Protection
Agency and Des I believe is the lead
Agency for applying for those funds so I
respectfully I I just don't know I think
Des would be a better person to ask
about that
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
Roberts yes thank you uh regarding
section four you recommended removing it
because doe has an open proceeding yes
can you speak more about that please
sure so uh per Senate Bill 262 from last
year
um the legislature required the
department to open up an investigatory
proceeding regarding interconnect
interconnection
um standards requirements procedures uh
obviously to make sure that they are I
wrote it down here
cost effective predictable and timely
interconnection uh procedures
um the department issued an order on
December 5th last year opening up that
proceeding and I could certainly provide
a link to that web page for the
committee uh public feedback was
requested and I believe the public
comment period closed at the end of
February I believe the department is in
the next step is in the process of
formulating next steps for that
proceeding
off the bat off the top of my head I
believe it's going to be largely you
know stakeholder sessions and that type
of thing but overall we prefer to let
that process play out before making any
changes here
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman um again I also
want to push back on on your insistence
that the language limiting utilities to
to a single pilot at a time
and your characterization that should
that language be removed
then
well then all kinds of Pilots could just
be
thrown out there isn't it true that for
any pilot program the utility must
carefully design and propose such
program to the Public Utilities
Commission and get their authorization
to implement that pilot program thank
you for the question that is correct
um but again I I and I hate to keep
adding on further context but there was
an extensive uh study committee or I
should I believe it was a commission
actually that looked at a revising the
leap of Statute to permit these types of
transactions to occur the overall study
found that you know this is this is
something that's very technical very
complex and requires further review
um obviously there's a number of steps
such as as you mentioned puc approval
and review going through those
jurisdictional issues uh beforehand
before these Pilots can be entertained I
think the department would submit just
letting it take one step at a time let's
clear you know the numerous hurdles
before us before jumping to that stage
but yes to your point the puc does
review and approve these projects
follow up thank you Mr chairman you know
again
uh given I think probably your testimony
but certainly the other testimony others
testimony Senator Waters description of
you know how the reason for this uh bill
for this effort proposed effort is that
everyone knows technology is moving fast
there are opportunities
to improve the way our grid functions
opportunities to take advantage of new
technologies
that can lower costs remember we're
asking questions not yes don't you I
don't you believe that they're that
there uh could be value in the ability
of utilities to test multiple
Technologies at uh that are different
from each other you know without waiting
for sequential I mean One Pilot could be
having to do with you know grid
connected EVS while another pilot could
have to do with a completely different
um
application so why should we be
restricting ourselves to One Pilot at a
time sure and again thank you for the
question again I would submit that if
you're allowing
projects to take Place With No Cap
whatsoever on the number that take place
it's no longer a pilot it's it's just
it's just a program any number of
projects can come forward I would submit
that again there are a number of of
steps there to take place before these
projects take place I think we should
let I think the department feels those
Pro those processes should play out
before entertaining statutory changes
such as this on line 29. if it is
something in the future that the
legislature wants to change that and
obviously if they want to do so now it's
certainly their prerogative to do so but
the Department's uh position at least on
the language is that it might be better
to remove that because it again is
essentially no longer a pilot any number
of projects can now just occur
can you refresh my memory about Senate
Bill 321 from last year
did it require the puc to
uh
adjudicate the jurisdictional issues
before any pilot Pro projects could be
proposed and that's correct yes I
thought so thank you any further
questions for the Department
representative partial has one thank you
chair Wells and thanks for coming today
thank you
um we were speaking about the RSA 378 uh
0.37 and the repeal of the least cost
integrative resource plan through House
Bill 281 yep and now that build I
understand is still in the Senate and
it's not yet a hearing yet yes and so
this bill is basically based on what is
current law correct okay and we may not
need to change that should the current
law stand correct uh I think the
department just wanted to know the con
note the conflict as the two bills kind
of work their way through the
legislature so thank you for putting
that out thank you
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
robesch for taking yet another question
from me
um I'd like to point us back to section
four on page four on
um
on open access to transmission and
distribution facilities because you had
mentioned that Senate Bill 262 which I
was a co-sponsor on
um it resulted in an open docket at the
puc on interconnection procedures and my
understanding was that that bill was
looking to get at the inconsistency in
the cost that people were incurring and
trying to make connections
um on different projects and the fact
that somebody need to needed to take
hold of it and figure out what what are
we charging here this section however
seems to be thoroughly in the purview of
the legislature in terms of trying to
require that we have a
non-discriminatory open access to the
Electric System so it's really still
part of I think the enabling language
that was intended here so
um perhaps you could speak to that
because I think again and I think I
talked to you about this on another bill
another day there are two different
things and so I don't think we should be
accepting one based on the others no and
thank you for the question so I I just
to clarify this investigatory seating is
as I mentioned assemble 262 is taking
place at the department not the puc
um I just want to clarify that no thanks
no offense intended um what was it um
again I think the department would feel
that having that
proceeding play out would be
advantageous before making
changes such as this obviously as I said
the legislature can certainly move
forward with this as is as is outlined
but again we would note that um there is
that reference to 378 colon 37 the
investigatory proceeding is still in its
early stages I think we'd like to see
that play out digest the public comment
get the feedback from the relevant
stakeholders before making changes to
this uh the section foreign statute
okay additional questions for the
Department
seeing none thank you and we'll move
along next I'll call Michael Licata from
eversource to give us the utility
perspective on this legislation
good morning again Michael Licata
representing eversource energy I
appreciate the opportunity to testify
before you on this bill uh eversource
supports the bill as amended by the
Senate uh that's in front of you today I
really just wanted to voice our
appreciation for Senator Waters hard
work on this legislation and his
willingness to work with eversource and
other stakeholders to address concerns
that we had with the bill as introduced
we think that uh the version before you
represents a good and reasonable
approach to move forward and make
progress on these issues having The
Advisory Group within the doe to
evaluate and come up with
recommendations for Public Policy makers
as yourself as well as the department
and the utilities is an approach that
we're certainly consistent with this
seems to be modeled after
similar legislation or similar advisory
group in in other states and we again
are supportive of legislation and would
be happy to answer questions that the
committee may have
well thank you very much appreciate you
being here so I have a quick question
for you how would you uh how do you view
the Department's characterization that
multiple pilot programs essentially
are not pilot programs that they're just
programs
um we had a number of concerns with the
changes to what I'll just call the Lipa
Pilots as folks who
were on the committee
last year know that there was quite a
bit of work done to strike a compromise
to allow those pilots pilots to move
forward so we were very concerned with
um
making changes to that compromise that
we did agree to as Mr Roberts said there
is an open adjudicative proceeding at
the commission to resolve
jurisdictional issues what is under the
purview of the state what is under the
purview of uh the Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission and so
you know we're comfortable with the
language that you have in front of you
it does represent
um an expansion uh however we feel that
uh the existing language
um in place uh has you know uh enough
rigor to uh you know have a thorough
review of whether it's a single pilot
offered by a utility or or more than one
pilot so we are comfortable with this
but certainly understand uh where the
department is coming from
okay thank you further questions
representative Corman has one thank you
Mr chairman thank you Mr locata I'm
looking at demand response and you know
I'm thinking all right I'm a residential
customer not of eversource but let's say
I work
um how would that actually work how how
would I know what to do
in terms of demand response so demand
response programs are are not new uh
they have been around for for many many
years
um the most common of them uh it has to
do with electric water heaters uh so if
you think about a water heater is
essentially a a thermal battery because
it contains hot water that's been heated
at certain points in time uh essentially
the utility has uh control over when
your water heater runs and when it
doesn't and so the customer that enrolls
in that probate program might be on a
specific rate structure or
receive a benefit associated with
allowing the utility to have
insight and control over that Appliance
now obviously it can get much more
sophisticated than that but that's
that's a good example that again has
been around for decades
follow-up follow up so then I as a
customer my only decision is I enroll or
I don't correct okay thank you
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair um I just
want to clarify when you said you were
comfortable with the language of the
bill does that mean you're comfortable
with removing line 29 on page four
that's this is regarding the pilot
program uh no I am comfortable with the
legislation oh yes I'm sorry I'm getting
my my removes the the the bill as
amended by the Senate we are supportive
of okay all right thank you thank you
sorry
additional questions for Mr locata
seeing none will move along and I'll ask
Mr The Honorable Clifton below to come
and give us his perspective on this
proposed legislation
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
I'm wondering if um a consultant with
the Coalition Samuel Golding who's just
filled out a pink card
um could join me here
um certainly okay
I would like to get the pink card though
oh send it up
thank you just for the record yes
certainly
um I am the chair of the community power
Coalition of New Hampshire it's a
non-profit New Hampshire Corporation
operating as a governmental
instrumentality of 32 municipalities in
one County our 33 our 32 Municipal
members comprise about 23 percent of the
state's population and includes the
cities of Nashua Portsmouth Dover Berlin
and Lebanon as well as uh quite a few
towns
and we are established uh to operate
Community power aggregation programs to
become an alternative to fault service
supplier for our communities and are in
the process of launching 10 to 12 of
those Community power programs this
spring
um and I'm we're here to testify in
general support for Senate Bill 321 and
I want to speak to
um a couple of the provisions here and
address the need uh to perhaps consider
further amendment to make the Lipa
Pilots or the Lipa provision actually
work and be something that can be
productive
um in general
um I would just note on the grid mod
Advisory Group that was a concept that
came out of a number of years of grid
mod investigation uh by the puc and was
a recommendation from puc staff at at
one point in time that at one point in
time the commission embraced but then
there was turnover and the composition
of the commission and it kind of got
dropped so that this revival of that
provides that important forum and it is
also particularly significant because
um uh
last August there was a ferc decision
that uh at the request of iso New
England that clarified that the
interconnection of all distributed
generation storage under five megawatts
are connected to the distribution grid
and not choosing to participate in the
iso New England RTO Market is purely
state jurisdictional that was never
clear before there was sort of
overlapping jurisdictional
interconnection and a lot of things got
deferred to ISO New England's
interconnection standards an ISO New
England basically said this doesn't make
sense for these smaller under five
megawatt projects
um we it and ferc actually said it would
be in the public interest to let these
be State jurisdictional because it would
actually allow them to inter connect
faster and the development of these
distributed generation and storage is
consistent with ferc's policy of
encouraging more generation and even if
it affects the the price in the
Interstate Wholesale Market they've said
it doesn't matter it's a good thing and
we're allowing that to be State
jurisdictional
um
so the the puc has started the
proceeding to determine the
jurisdictional issue
um and some people might say well that's
a little odd that the commission itself
is deciding jurisdiction but that's
pretty standard with with any judicial
or quasi-judicial body threshold issues
do we have jurisdiction to decide this
issue
um and we're confident we'll Prevail on
the jurisdictional issue if for no other
reason simply that over these uh past a
year or so these two major ferc
decisions have for all practical
purposes said that these smaller
projects are under State jurisdiction
and they can be treated as load reducers
relative to transmission cost allocation
relative to capacity cost allocation
relative to energy cost allocation and
an example of that is on the handout and
I just kind of want to walk you through
this because in some ways Unitil has
made the case for us with regard to the
potential value and how these projects
could be compensated and hopefully
everybody has that handout it has some
yellow head lighting these are simply
excerpts from the petition and a
testimony that Unitil submitted in an
ongoing docket it's actually having its
hearing tomorrow at the puc and what
they argued was that utility scale
renewable projects such as the 4.99
megawatt project they're proposing
provides tangible benefits to customers
the this distribution system and the
environment and they say the benefits
include reductions to purchased energy
Peak demand and line losses and they go
on and say they include avoided
transmission costs local transmission
savings Regional transmission savings as
well as wreck savings so they say they
operate plan to operate as a load
reducer and later on they say this is
they'll do this because they will not
register the asset with ISO New England
and importantly at the bottom of page
one they note that New Hampshire ranks
47th among all states and the amount of
electricity produced by large capacity
utility scale Projects New Hampshire is
significant untapped potential in the
utility scale solar sector that remains
to be unlocked for the benefit of
customers and what they're talking about
in particular is projects in this under
five megawatt size that can function as
load reducers and probably that's sort
of three to five five megawatt size that
you've kind of heard there's pent-up
demand for an opportunity for in in the
net metering arguments well they go on
and on page two provide more of these
details there's a little bit of red text
here which is my own commentary they
point out the commission the company is
in unique position to deliver benefits
that would not otherwise be available if
the project were developed by a private
entity and generally that's true when
you look at the way net metering or
group net metering works but the Lipa
market-based alternative
as
uh enabled as a pilot
deals with capturing the exact same
value stack that Unitil is making the
case for their project on
and I might add that the department of
energy the consumer Advocate and clean
energy New Hampshire have all joined
with Unitil in endorsing this doe did
its own analysis of the benefits and
concluded that unitil's analysis was
sound that the benefits are real the
prospective benefits exceed the cost and
are recommending the commission to prove
this project under 374 G
um and they and and I think the only
reason
um others can't deliver these values for
rate payers is because of the lack of a
of a market-based alternative to realize
these values
and uh
if you turn to page three here here are
the key points they explain
um uh four major pieces of value
and these are again the exact same
values that are proposed to be enabled
through the Lipa Pilots
and they include avoided energy costs
avoided capacity cost which by the way
they explain that these are actually
very simple calculations these are not
going to be difficult to quantify or
determine in fact the formula is
basically spelled out here it's the
product of generation output at the peak
hour
at the estimated capacity clearing price
or it could be the actual clearing price
there's a quantifiable benefit and value
local transmission and which was one of
eversource's big bugaboos about
jurisdiction
um they say that's easily computed
because it's the product of generation
output at the monthly peak hour and the
annualized transmission rate
and also the same thing for ancillary
services and the same thing for regional
transmission benefits these are the
exact same value propositions the exact
same rate elements contemplated for the
Lipa Pilots
um and I might add that nobody has
questioned the jurisdiction of the
commission to approve this treatment
eversource is not intervened in the case
saying no you can't get credit for
avoided transmission costs by reducing
uh the Generation by reducing your load
on the transmission system what ferc
said in in their decision last year is
yes any of these projects that are under
five megawatts
can function as load reducers
meaning they reduce the allocation of
transmission costs because they're not
actually using the transmission system
at the the system Peaks a coincident
Peaks when costs are incurred
um
and and it's almost that simple you know
and so
um where this leads us to
um and and I'm going to have Mr Golding
here speak a little bit about
um
trying to avoid the mistakes that other
states have done like California and
that Massachusetts is well on the way uh
to digging themselves in a hole on by
not enabling these market-based
mechanisms to recognize the temporal
value or lack of value for distributed
energy resources
and
um to help think this through I have
provided on page five a copy of the uh
relevant uh definitions in the leapis uh
chapter as well as on pages six and
seven and eight that's the text of the
existing law that was enacted last year
by this committee
for enabling these Pilots
and then on starting on page nine we
have some uh suggestions
um and we realize this is a lot and I
I'm only going to partially go through
some of the detail here my ask for the
committee is that you would consider uh
taking some time with this bill I think
you have four weeks before you have to
report this bill to take a look at this
question of whether there may actually
be a very beneficial opportunity here to
enable a market-based approach
consistent with the state's energy
strategy that can avoid all the problems
of cost shifting and uh the concerns
that have been raised around for
instance expanding net group net
metering through this as this
market-based cost causation based
approach
um
and so um one of the issues here is that
the way about the bill has passed
um or the law as it exists today
um this is purely voluntary by the
utilities it leaves it for the utilities
to exercise the initiative and uh quite
honestly in our experience of trying to
launch community power aggregations and
only discovering at the last minute that
the utilities will not share data to
enable us to provide time of use rates
or net metering rates
um it's it's kind of apparent that the
utilities
are are pretty resistance to to the kind
of meaningful uh change that we need uh
to to enable these cost-saving
opportunities
um so because it relies particularly
only on the utilities to volunteer Our
concern is that we Prevail in the
jurisdictional issue and we're prepared
to go to the U.S Supreme Court if
necessary because we're confident we'll
Prevail on the jurisdictional issue just
like nobody's questioning the
jurisdiction of the puc to approve the
exact same uh values with Unitil that
will get through that and the utilities
will say no thanks we're not interesting
doing Pilots we'll do these projects
ourselves under 374 G you know it's it's
it's purely at our discretion because
that's what the current law says
um
so
um one of the suggestions is to clarify
the jurisdictional question and that's
if you look on page nine of um the
handout and I'm referring to the big red
numbers the sort of Bates page numbers
um it's really the question is whether
the jurisdiction has uh to the the
jurisdiction to regulate sales of
electricity and give credit for avoided
costs for energy capacity transmission
and Ansley Services provided by or
through ISO New England as Allowed by
this section also there's a reference to
the chapter up above which is really
broad because it includes net metering
and I think that probably should be
sectioned just from a technical point of
view
so it suggests that if they resolve
those then they have an adjudicated
Precision to determine how to implement
the pilot programs as Allowed by the
section
and it does uh in this option
um propose that the cap
on uh net metering I'm not let me this
is not net metering
um on these uh projects uh be uh limited
to five megawatts and overall allowed
export capacity the distribution Grid at
the point of interconnection but allow
if it consists of both generation and
storage for each to be up to that limit
provided the total interconnection never
exceeds physically is constrained to
less than five megawatts this is
something that unitel themselves has
suggested in their filing they said
we're going to do 4.99 because that's
where it keeps stays under State
jurisdiction and we'd like to look at uh
addering battery storage to this project
in the future and a really important
aspect that's interesting about the
Unitil proposal is for the first time
instead of just a rack system that's
facing due south that produces the most
kilowatt hours at solar noon and less in
the morning in the evening they're
proposing a single axis tracker that
rotates from east to west so they
improve the production profile in the
morning and in the late afternoon it's
more of a a flat shape rather than just
this hump
um because when you add the dynamic
temporal value
it makes more sense to look at a
different technology that can capture
those Dynamic values such as reducing
coincident peak in the later afternoon
so that is one concept
um right now the bill limits pilot
projects to 10 years part of the problem
is these projects typically are analyzed
based on a 20-year lifestyle fan minimum
uh units is projecting 30 to 40 years
for that project but they're basing the
cost benefit on a 20-year cycle so to
say we have to you know make my concern
is the current language for Pilots is a
setup for failure they also in the bill
as passed by the Senate it appears to
raise the cap on Pilots uh to five
megawatts
um but I'm looking at the wrong bill
um
oh here it is
um but if you look carefully I want to
turn you back to the text of the bill at
um
on page four section six of the bill
at uh line 28 does say projects shall be
limited to five megawatts in overall
size but then when you turn the page on
page five
um still referring to the same issue at
line four it says if the jurisdictional
conflicts under paragraph three are
successfully resolved the commission can
increase the allowed size of Pilots to
two megawatts
um which is less than what was
previously provided for utility serving
less than 20 percent of New Hampshire
load which would be Unitil and um uh
Liberty and up to five megawatts for any
utility serving more than 50 percent of
New Hampshire load well I think as
you've heard two megawatts is not The
Sweet Spot the cost to do
interconnection for one or two megawatt
project can be as much as to do a four
or five megawatt projects with you know
half or a third of the amount of
kilowatt hours to spread that
interconnection cost for
um so as Unitil makes the case The Sweet
Spot is right up to 4.99 megawatts where
you get the most value so limiting
Pilots to two megawatts just is a setup
for
um failure I'm concerned
can we interrupt you for a question okay
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
below for taking my question when the
doe testified they suggested that we
put a period after the word successfully
resolved and eliminate the rest of the
sentence on page five
uh starting at line five and so I'm
wondering whether that would resolve the
limitations that you see the that appear
to be inconsistent yes that that would
help to at least um allow a single or at
least allow project up to up to five
megawatts I might add
well the Senate Bill 321 is passed last
year by the Senate didn't have any caps
on pilots and
um I I just want to
um
uh I'm quickly hit on a few points and
wrap up and let Mr Golden say a little
bit
um about the bigger picture here uh but
um on page 10 of the handout there is
some additional language it does call uh
for each distribution utility shall
participate in one or more pilots
um and calls for the puc
to actually
allow the size of Pilots to be up to 15
megawatts for utility serving less than
20 percent of New Hampshire's load and
up to 30 megawatts for any utility
serving more than 50 percent of New
Hampshire's loads in other words Unitil
and Liberty up to 15 megawatts
ever Source up to 30. for the smaller
that could be just three four or five
projects for 30 that's maybe half a
dozen seven or eight projects
um and we think there's probably dozens
and dozens of opportunities where this
can be cost effective and produce
significant net direct benefits to rate
payers plus very substantial indirect
benefits in terms of economic activity
uh and other benefits that are actually
analyzed and Quantified by Unitil but
aren't even used to fully to justify in
the cost benefit test
the last part of the handout starting on
page 13 is another alternative which I
think you might seriously want to
consider if you really want New
Hampshire to follow its state energy
strategy and the original intent of
restructuring which is to enable a
competitive market using appropriate
price signals to uh a drive Innovation
and produce value for rate payers in a
way that avoids cost shifting or
subsidization altogether
um and and nobody's raised the issue
that what unitels is doing is creating
cross-subsidy or subsidization because
they're just they're actually
quantifying the actual Financial
benefits of reducing load at coincident
Peak it's it's almost that simple and
quite honestly our other New England
states are chasing that same idea with
aggressive demand response and storage
programs so absent enabling something
like this New Hampshire is likely see an
increasing share of the total
transmission cost allocation let me stop
there and I would like to ask Mr Golding
to talk about why this is an opportunity
to help New Hampshire prevent some of
the mistakes that uh perhaps we might be
headed toward if the only option for
this kind of distributed generation is
the kind of a group net metering we have
where the utilities paying the full cost
of what is exported to the grid and
charging to to to the group charging
that uh to rate payers is a stranded
cost or delivery charge and then not
even counting that output as an offset
to to the members of the group the same
the members of the group have to just
turn around and buy those in kilowatt
hours and pay for them on top of um
being a member of the group so they're
not even actually off takers in that
construct
thank you
um as Cliff mentioned
um
well I'll take a step back
so New Hampshire's competitive market
has stalled in terms of its ability to
serve an increasing customer base and
create new customer value so about four
out of five customers remain on utility
administered default service with the
Advent of community power we intend for
significant volumes of customers to
access competitive markets and price
signals as Cliff mentioned the Coalition
has discovered that it is not possible
to offer through the utilities as
Community power as opposed to as
competitive suppliers are supposed to be
able to it is not possible to offer
Innovative rate structures three-part
time of use or net energy metering
on the same sort of Technology platform
the Billing System the median system
that the utility is owning operating and
controlling to provide those same sorts
of value enabling services to the mass
Market customer base this bill is about
the section that Cliff was just
referring to is about whether or not and
how to allow competitive market entities
to
construct small scale resources
throughout New Hampshire's communities
as every single distribution utility has
either proposed or is currently doing
or whether those should continue to be
viewed as somehow utility Pilots right
that the utilities May propose or kind
of have
control over designing how they play out
and so I'd like to point out that you
know
markets that are markets can't work if
they're designed to fail to put it
simply
utilities have a regulated business
model in which they invest Capital into
the distribution grid and the
transmission Network and they're paid a
return on that capital
so they have an overriding incentive not
to lower Peak demand because whenever
customers are all using electricity at
the same times on the local grid and the
regional transmission Network it
increases the size that those grids have
to be so there's just a direct line
between and financial conflict between
having the utilities be The Gatekeepers
to projects and services that are
based on market price signals and our
incentivizing customers and communities
to lower coincident Peak demand
if
yeah so with that as just kind of the
general context
um
this sort of situation this is kind of
Market design Distortion you find across
a lot of different states California
Massachusetts all the kind of partially
restructured states where actually a lot
of customers have remained on default
service administered by utilities and
utilities have remained in control of
metering and billing you often find that
the Practical reality is competitive
suppliers and aggregators simply cannot
innovate to the same degree using the
same systems as the utilities are using
for their own programs and so
far enough down that path what
inevitably happens
is legislatures and utility commissions
start to
think that the only way forward to
create Innovation and change and to kind
of accommodate
um the challenges that may otherwise
destabilize the grid going forward
is to further empower the utilities to
rely on the utilities to administer
programs to rely on the state Regulatory
Commission to somehow evolve those
programs
and the competitive markets start to
fail because they just can't they can't
create value right
um
that's kind of
the deeper story of what has been
happening I I believe in California for
about 15 years
and the you know
the grids are there's a lot of variable
Renewables with gnome fuel costs coming
on to these networks
um
to balance that the whole kind of
strategy is to incentivize demand
flexibility and lots of intelligently
managed local generation which can be
um ratcheted up or down in response to
market price signals which are a proxy
for grid stability right so price spikes
that's actually the underlying driver of
that is often if it's you know it could
be fuel costs marginal dispatch but then
at a certain point it's actually Rising
because the grid needs to shed load in
certain locations to balance Supply
demand
and if you can't do that then you start
to have real issues
um
the lack of that sort of
distributed market-driven Nimble
intelligent self-balancing
um
grid
drives the cost of electricity way up in
other words it it makes the whole system
efficient
inefficient can I interrupt you for just
a second one more sentence because I'm
about to finish okay finish your point
thanks
um
and then
that actually undermines the entire
ability of the system to continue
evolving because customers do not find
it in their financial interest to to
Electrify their vehicles Electrify their
water heaters and so on and so forth
that is actually playing out in
California right now and that is the
pathway that a lot of New England states
are on and this is the opportunity to
kind of come out and get ahead of the
entire pack and show how to do it
correctly
please
so the reason I interrupted you is
because fascinating as this discussion
is it has wandered it seems to me quite
a way is from the subject before us
which is Senate bill 166.
so unless you can
tie your discussion specifically to
Senate Bill 166 I'd like to move on
sure the point of all of that was to
underscore how inappropriate it is to be
viewing the utilities as the ones that
should be driving this they more
appropriately should be viewed as the
administrators the managers of these
metering and data systems and right now
we have them using those systems to
perform the same calculations required
to make these projects work
that could be extended open access to
the competitive market forces so in
other words Community power aggregators
and competitive suppliers could be
proposing these projects and the
utilities wouldn't have kind of a
gatekeeping ability or much role other
than okay you now perform the same
calculations you're doing for your
project over here unitiler and all of
them for this new project that's
actually arms length between a
competitive market entity and its
customer base
if I made quickly um just to tie this
off
um the the Lipa alternative is a way to
do uh to enable
market-based development of projects
under five megawatts that don't require
um
subsidy or cross uh
cost shifting
um
that would enable the projects to be
responsive to Dynamic price signals
rather than our current construct under
net meeting which is all kilowatt hours
are the same and when you say all
kilowatt hours are valued equally I I
think that's going to evolve in the net
metering proceeding at the puc but it
doesn't it doesn't uh you end up digging
a hole in terms of solar noon which
we're already starting to see in New
England where prices can dip very low in
the middle of the day and and yet we're
valuing those kilowatts the same as the
kilowatt hours that are produced uh
later in the day when you're helping
offset a coincident Peak demand so the
point is this this is an as Unitil has
shown in economically viable way to
develop projects that doesn't involve
cross-subsidy that can benefit all rate
payers and and and and the projects
would evolve in a market-based concept
context to be selected to to there'd be
competitive procurement where the most
cost effective projects make sense right
now it's any project can make sense if
it can if it works off of the full
default service rate for all kilowatt
hours that's not a model for future
success and future grid stability that
that's our point
I I would wonder have you discussed uh
this with Senator Waters because the
path you're putting us on is a path to
retaining this bill
and I don't know if Senator Waters wants
to go that direction but the
complexities that you're introducing
here
are not complexities that I think we can
deal with you mentioned that we have
four weeks left well I'm not sure that's
enough time to deal with all this
well maybe take a look at some of it and
see what you can do we you know would
like to see the bill move forward but
we'd also like to see a meaningful
opportunity at least for Pilots that
that can can make economic sense
okay questions from the committee
representative McGee has a question Mr
chairman this is actually a comment to
you I'm I'm wondering whether we could
try and put together a work
session to examine these amongst
ourselves a little more closely
it's possible but we'll have to discuss
that later yeah
further questions representative
Reynolds has a question well thank you
Mr chairman and I guess my question is
going to hopefully be responsive to your
comment but it's a question to the
witness aren't you I'm just interpreting
all of your
your testimony to be
in support of the elements of
SB 166 that make some changes to the
definitions and the scope of pilot
projects it isn't it I mean that
the bill I think the amendments are that
simple but obviously you've provided us
with a lot of
reason
for doing so would you would you agree
with that
yes and I I won't mention I think the
chair did a very good effort to try to
figure out the right language for the
the chair and the other members of the
committee that worked on this to try to
uh try to create a pilot that could work
there wasn't a lot of opportunity for
discussion in terms of the final text of
the bill
um so I think some of these things are
trying to address those elements that um
and and some of the text on page 10
concern concerns the fact that there's
some language in the existing
um uh uh statute that is actually quite
hard to interpret and so
um would appreciate the opportunity to
spend a little bit more time with those
to see if we can't
in Fairly short order figure out a
bipartisan sort of fix that that can uh
actually make this a viable option that
we can explore as a state
other questions for The Honorable Mr
below uh representative lewicki has a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for being here and this is probably
not a well-formed question because some
a lot of this is new to me but it
appears that in your document you're
talking about moving people to a demand
basis you know rather than default
service and
for many of us that's just electricity
is just not an expense that we even
think about because you know they split
the bill so now two-thirds of it is
transmission and one-third is actual
cost of electricity and I get these
bozos that excuse the expression call me
up and say switch over to hours and
lower your electric rate and we're
talking about the difference between you
know thirty dollars a month and uh
twenty dollars a month and it's just
like it's just a nuisance and so why
would I switch to a demand situation on
something that is such a small part of
my existence
there's nothing really in this bill
that's about an individual residential
customer in fact the pilots and and
nothing in this uh suggestions changes
it is is
residential customers can't even
participate you know as a potential you
know off taker if you will uh for these
limited producers so it right now it's
structured so it's for suppliers
um like competitive suppliers or
Community power aggregations as a
potential power source and for larger
commercial industrial customers who can
uh for whom there is value in terms of
responding to these price signals for
instance
and just to put this in the the cost
benefits and context uh the community
power Coalition conducted Financial
modeling and energy modeling looking out
over about a five-year six year period
um and these projects provided that they
are compensated for saving uh or for
creating the benefits they save in terms
of avoiding transmission costs and
distribution costs or transmission and
generation capacity costs in addition to
energy
um they generate twice as much value for
customers as the contract cost required
to build the new resource
and that from a portfolio perspective
saves about 30 percent it's 30 percent
cheaper to Source electricity from
small scale in-state assets than it is
to continue just buying wholesale power
and paying for its delivery into the
state so so as Cliff mentioned there's
quite a few that I mean there could be
quite a number of these projects being
built by market forces just based on
those economics alone providing
significant rate relief to customers
large and small particularly through
these Community power aggregators that
are beginning to launch this year
mm-hmm
okay representative Kaplan has a
question yeah just a curiosity question
you you um you mentioned you've done
studies and you've uh you've costed it
out the benefit of uh growth in the
community projects as you outlined in
your in your handout here do you
actually have uh
you know project developers that have
contacted you in terms of 15 to 30
megawatt utilities not under five
megawatts is all we're looking at the 15
or 30 would allow several of those uh
and and yes particularly as
um we've become more visible in the news
we've had numerous uh developers reach
out to us including a number who've
secured very good sites and have
interconnection POS you know figured out
the interconnection uh that they've been
sort of stockpiling with the expectation
that net metering would expand to five
megawatts in general
um uh but this is another alternative
that I think uh you know they're seeing
that this is another viable alternative
if this actually moves ahead
um so yes I think there's a lot of
potential projects out there
that that will that will make sense in a
market-based construct
but they also make sense under group net
metering so they're going to go
whichever one is enabled first
okay thank you very much you've given us
a lot to uh think about here and I
apologize I had a necktied layout this
morning and I forgot to bring it with me
no apology needed
well I had hoped to avoid this but it
doesn't look like we're going to be able
to do so I had hoped that we'd hear all
of these bills in one block and then end
our day but it's gone on too long we
haven't had a break now for almost three
and a half hours so I'm gonna have to
call a lunch break
and bring everybody back here at 150 and
I apologize Senator Waters I I had hoped
that you could
okay so we're gonna break now and we'll
be back at 1 15. we have three more
speakers on 166 and then we have five on
167. so plan on being here I'd say at
least until probably 2 30 or 3 o'clock
thank you and we'll see you at 1 15.
thank you
seems
potatoes
it really you know
this week
right now
benefits
um
example
and um
yeah
it is a part of the issue is
just going to stay on the screen Museum
[Music]
thank you
foreign
you get more and more hours
but if
there's a big price drop for everyone if
you ship that scene
um uh low to off the low price period
when the price bit stack is fair goes to
the flat they only increase a little bit
that you save a lot and we don't have a
dynamic
okay
I said
it was still trying to fit that into it
from this idea I mean you know
all right I'm just trying to land this
airplane
right
and just just before
is
all right
but only recently yeah
so
foreign
all right
okay
students
me personally
and into people on to be blocked
if it's just under the current metering
concert you open it up
sites that would be better under this
but for the ratepayers
as well because there's problems with
the lettering or net metering is just
don't really know what the long that Dan
can speak to this you you don't have
necessarily
um a price certainty over time
you know
this is the entire training for these
size projects in a better it's a better
alternative for these size projects than
trying to push them into the existing
net meter Wisconsin
which quite obviously
when I
um
thank you
foreign
okay everyone please take your seats
it's 1 16. I'd like to resume
the public hearing on Senate Bill 166 we
have one person
who remains to be heard from and that's
Henry Herndon
uh
who used to be
representing someone else but now is
representing himself I guess so Henry
welcome aboard and uh please give us
your perspective on Senate bill 166.
thank you chairman thank you members of
the committee
um I I am a consultant here in the state
and I had the privilege of actually
working with this Committee in 2021 when
House Bill 315 moved forward and really
made the community power act uh viable
and realistic for the state and I'm
pleased to sort of report to you all
today that
um the fruits of that good legislation
that good collaborative bipartisan
legislation are coming to fruition we're
seeing Community power programs launch
all across the state just with the
Coalition Community power Coalition of
New Hampshire 10 programs are currently
going live and we'll be saving tens of
thousands of granite Staters tens of
millions of dollars annually on their
electricity Supply costs so that is all
as a result of the good work of this
committee and the collaborative process
there
and
um I want to I'd like to sort of clarify
I hope some of the discussion around the
pilots and the projects and what are the
options before this committee with
regard specifically to section five and
section uh sorry section six and section
seven of this bill on page four
um we have heard discussion about
pilot projects of up to five megawatts
we've heard discussion of Monopoly
utility projects of the same sort and
we've heard discussion of a potential
Marketplace for developing those same
projects and I think these are sort of
the three Pathways available to the
committee and I'll try to sort of share
some I hope helpful context and then
answer questions about
um a path pot potentially forward
um the bill I think it does a great job
of laying out the framework and then
it's about sort of what can be done now
to directly build on the good progress
of things like the the competitive
market expansion under Community power
and
um
I mentioned some of the cost savings
we're seeing in these cities and towns
Supply rates drop from 20 cents for
eversource or 26 Cents for Unitil all
the way down to below 16 cents in some
cases as low as 12 cents in some of
these communities so dramatic savings
twenty to fifty dollars a month per
customer
and what the technical analysis from
Community power Coalition has found is
that while this new community power
structure creates cost savings
it can further create cost savings if it
is able to contract directly within
State generators under five megawatts if
we can contract with those generators we
can realize further cost Savings in a
competitive market structure so
we there's not really a disagreement on
the value as was described by Clifton
below
um you know Unitil has proposed a very
similar project realizing all of the
same benefits
avoided wholesale energy cost avoided
wholesale capacity cost avoided
transmission costs avoided ancillary
Services costs we understand all of
these values can be realized utilities
are to their credit proposing these
projects to move forward under sort of a
utility monopoly-centric approach which
I I think is good because it's you know
one Avenue to develop these projects
what the opportunity that is before this
committee is to allow both utilities and
Market actors to implement the same
kinds of projects to realize benefits so
really the question I think the question
this committee often struggles with is
when do we have monopolies do things
when do we have Market actors do things
which one is more efficient when and and
how can we sort of set the right
structures and the opportunity with this
bill is to create in addition to the
Monopoly structure for one to five
megawatt projects a market-based
structure where Community power programs
can do the same projects competitive
suppliers can do the same projects and
basically you do you do the math the
same way and you let the marketplace
realize those benefits across the state
so
um
that's I think the question and
um I know I'm in support of this bill
I'm in support of potentially
a collaborative process to amend the
bill I remember sort of uh
it was exciting a couple of years ago to
see this very collaborative project
process led by the chairman to bring
together Market actors non-profits local
cities and towns utility companies and
sort of how do we flesh out public
policy that that meets all of those
interests it seems that there may be an
opportunity for some sort of work
session on this bill which has a lot of
potential but I don't it's kind of clear
perhaps it's not fully fleshed out as of
yet as to exactly how do we allow for
these projects do we say hey utility
voluntarily you can build these pilots
on a one-off basis if you'd like to do
we say utilities can build these
projects and allow Market actors to
propose them
um those questions seem slightly
unresolved and the legislation has
drafted
and I think that's really the decision
of the committee so I can I can conclude
my remarks there and I'd be happy to
answer questions and particularly with
these interest in understanding like how
these look why these are valuable what
is transmission avoided cost and you
know how how is that realized through
these projects I could speak to that or
I could speak to any other questions the
committee may have thank you
thank you representative Nader has a
question yeah just for the record um how
do you spell your name I couldn't read
your writing oh uh it's Henry h-e-n-r-y
Herndon h-e-r-n-d-o-n
thank you and by the way to the rest of
the committee thanks to representative
Nutter today for filling in for our
clerk who is obviously not here today JD
Bernardi he uh had
a private business that he had to attend
to today
okay
questions for Mr Herndon representative
Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair
um you said you'd be willing to work on
an amendment specifically what aspect
would you like to see amended is that
the whole pilot program thing
I think that
um there's been materials proposed by
Clifton below there's the the language
that is currently in this in section six
and seven and
um
I think that yes that is what would need
to be fleshed out I don't have specific
language for you right now but I think
it is a question of
shall we allow a very limited voluntary
number of Pilots shall we require a
certain number of Pilots or shall we
open a Marketplace to allow
Market actors to propose and develop
projects and I would recommend that
third option is actually the best public
policy you want to avoid a death by
Pilot situation
um where you know you have these Pilots
they drag on in regulatory bodies for
year after year and and they they
sometimes they don't get to the Finish
Line
um the committee's been successful in
the past at implementing good public
policy that creates real value like the
millions of dollars of savings that
Community power is currently generating
and I think a sort of open a Marketplace
Third Road as opposed to restricted
Pilots Road uh that would be my
recommendation but that's obviously
something for the committee to to
deliberate thank you I follow up I have
a follow-up but it's actually for
Senator Waters
is that appropriate
Senator waters are you prepared to
answer a question for
okay hold it until after he's done all
right representative Corman has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr Herndon for taking my question so
as you said if Community power can can
contract with small generators that can
actually produce even more savings and
as I understand it a lot of these
savings would be due to reduced
transmission costs so I live in Lebanon
so I'm actually about to go on community
power very happily so if Community power
in Lebanon were to contract with a
supplier near Lebanon then presumably
the transmission cost is
saved or reduced but if they were to
contract with the supplier in say Berlin
would there still be the transmission
costs and would that limit how much
Lebanon Community power could save
that's a good question
the transmission cost would be reduced
if the generator produces power at the
hour of the month at which transmission
load is highest and that's measured and
that's pretty simple calculation looking
backwards what hour of this month was
the peak transmission load did Generator
X produce power at that hour of Time how
much power that's how much less cost so
that's the calculation and really the
the factor is not whether it's in
Lebanon or not I believe it is whether
it is interconnected into the same
utility company's distribution grid so
if if the generator is plugged into the
Liberty Utilities distribution grid
beneath the transmission grid then it
could if generating power at the time of
peak transmission cost it would reduce
those costs directly and that's very
measurable and easy to calculate
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Herndon for taking my question I think
it might be helpful for the committee if
you uh entered into an exercise to try
and help us understand how pilot
projects are being used within this bill
because
um I think they're you know the word
pilot seems to be all things to all
people
um there's a specific reference to
utility Pilots but then there's places
where it just says pilot and it seems to
be a bit of a contention so if you could
just clarify for us what we're talking
about here
pilots and projects are not
interchangeable correct
that's a good question and and no they
they're not interchangeable
um and I'll sort of recall what the
gentleman from the Department of energy
said about well if you have multiple
projects they're no longer a pilot and
that's he sort of seemed to view it as a
bad thing
um and and I would I would posit that
actually the opposite is true if you
know that value can be created by a
project if you measure its production at
a certain time why would we restrict
that value from being available to all
customers in New Hampshire this is why I
would propose to the committee that
rather than piloting or studying this
consider strongly the possibility of
allowing it through sort of the correct
authorizations through the Public
Utility Commission to determine how do
we calculate value but not restricting
it to only Pilots that could be
controlled by utilities or that
utilities might be able to sort of
have a hand in the timeline or the or
the project development or that you know
they could potentially obstruct those
projects
[Music]
times on this committee we're concerned
with any type of unrestrained adoption
of anything in terms of the energy
markets but um could you speak to if
there were greater diversity uh
in the supply
whether that would help affect rates
because I think that's something we're
all concerned with
yes
um
so the way these projects would move
forward is a buyer and a seller would
negotiate a power purchase agreement how
much do we want to buy so that's a
market price between two participants
free of government intervention
and then you say if you do certain
things like lower transmission cost
we're going to pay you for lowering this
transmission costs now there's an
incentive for Market actors to lower
everyone in New Hampshire's electricity
costs so again a key aspect of this
structure this Market market-based
structure is there is no
cross-subsidization this is not net
metering where the state is picking the
price and paying the that that is paid
out to the generator this is a negotiate
agreement with no possibility of
Shifting costs one way for or another
but it does allow the possibility to
lower costs if they hit certain things
like transmission monthly Peaks
representative munz did you have a
question no
representative Reynolds
thank you Mr chairman uh
Henry is it
um inherent in your stated preference
for
as you described at the the third option
um for amending uh potentially amending
section six and seven with reference to
Pilots that
do I am I correct that you were
advocating
you know rather rather than allowing or
even requiring utilities to do one pilot
each
uh which would then give policy makers a
limited set of
experiments
and data to inform future policy that
you're saying let there be more pilots
let there be more experience and then
policymakers could compare the results
would have more they have a bigger data
set from which to draw on
making future policy
yes I believe I am saying that and I'm
saying that you know right now Unitil
has proposed a very good project outside
of this construct and that's good and
that should be allowed to move forward
and similarly we should allow projects
to move forward to realize those same
benefits for customers and have sort of
an all of the above approach rather than
um
you know really it's not a question of
should we allow utilities to do pilots
it's a question of should we allow the
market to develop cost-effective
projects
thank you
representative lowkey has a question uh
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um I have a question about who the
generators are because presumably these
would be dispatchable sources as opposed
to you know some of the Renewables and
um why would these you know other
generators be cheaper than
um the grid that's a very good question
um
in the Unitil example you know they've
they've proposed this tracker to follow
the sun right and and so you solve for
this issue of let's just have Solar
without
caring when it's producing power so you
create an incentive where the project in
Lebanon for example it could have a
landfill gas to energy power plant that
could be this that would be a
dispatchable resource or you could have
a developer say oh I'm gonna get paid
for lowering transmission cost if I
attach a battery to my solar array and I
dispatch that battery once a month on
the transmission cost so you leave it to
the market to say we created the
incentive hit these monthly transmission
Peaks and let the market figure out what
resource or project is best equipped for
that
all right thank you
okay seeing no further questions from
the committee I want to thank you for
being here to testify and then I'll
close the public hearing finally Mr
chair I had that question for the
senator oh that's right okay I forgot
about that thank you so Senator waters
before we start on 167 can you answer
representative I'll Trust these
questions thank you I think you can
answer this
um so much of the discussion today has
been on the definition of pilot programs
and and modifying and amending the
language when this was presented in the
Senate was there pushback or discussion
on the pilot program issue or is this a
house specific issue
um thanks for your question you betcha
there was discussion and that's why we
ended up where we ended and why we got
the ever source to say they were pretty
happy who they ended up because there's
a lot of negotiating over that and doe
got itself to neutral on it my advice on
this
um basically I don't I don't think
there's any disagreement on maybe
needing to tweak the pilots a little bit
so they'll work better in the
marketplace and the side nobody's
complained about moving the size of the
project a little bit I think the
question is
um on how many
and I think there's a way to work with
doe and others to to kind of figure out
something in between on that
um let me just a little context too the
wisdom of this committee and
particularly your chair in the way we
got to compromise on 315 and 165 you
know a few years ago was to use this
pilot concept as a way to help the
marketplace but also understand what
we're doing as we're setting policy and
I and I I think that was a that was a
good move so
um I think that within the framework
there I think we can make some
adjustments in the bill I don't see a
lot of disagreement frankly over this
it's a Way Forward I do think from what
we've heard we're going to be coming
back to this issue and trying to do more
as things evolve but for now I think
there's a kind of a good little
compromise available here thank you very
much
okay
now we can say we're officially done
with Senate bill 166.
and so we will move on to Senate bill
167.
and I'll open that public hearing and
recognize Senator David Waters Prime
sponsor of the bill to speak to us about
this bill Senator Waters thank you very
much Mr chairman members of the
committee Senator David Waters District
4 introducing Senate Bill 167 relative
to Green hydrogen energy and
infrastructure
um this bill uh I put together with a
lot of help from other people to make a
bad pun when we're getting to power uh
many hands make the lights work and uh
so here I wanted to be sure that as this
emerging industry comes forward and this
this fuel source that New Hampshire is
open for business
um I think hydrogen has a great
possibility of reducing our energy costs
and promoting uh Economic Development
there is major industry investment
coming into the hydrogen space as the
cost of electrolyzing is expected to
drop fast in the next few years and I
think that we see the great potential of
what hydrogen uh can can do
um uh and I just mentioned uh in terms
of other support for this the
Transportation Act included 7.1 billion
dollars for pilot programs related to
hydrogen infrastructure
um most of the all the New England
states except for New Hampshire and
uh Mid-Atlantic coaster and a Consortium
New Hampshire is considering the
governor's considering joining that
Consortium might help us leverage some
of that 7.1 billion dollars there also
are tens of billions of dollars for
hydrogen infrastructure development in
the ira Act
major investments in r d stackable tax
credits up to 36 percent for projects
and a price guarantee for hydrogen
um particularly important to Hampshire
is that those those kinds of fundings
might be available for New Generation
yes but also for replacement existing
generation that that's something that's
important for us also great potential in
Marine hydrogen
Transportation hydrogen I suspect our
heavy truck Fleet is more likely to go
hydrogen than it is electrification
we'll see but there is a lot of money
available for transportation hubs for
hydrogen fueling then of most importance
to me in terms of offshore wind is
offshore wind is likely to use hydrogen
as a Storage Fuel producing it at the
turbine site and using it as a Storage
Fuel that can then be put to generation
or industrial or other usage
in this bill I Look to Montana to
Illinois some of the western states as
to what they're trying to do about it
and I tried to put together a bill which
I thought would
you know kind of be right for New
Hampshire and get us into a regulatory
and tax framework where we could get
some of this major investment into
our our state so we're turning to the
bill
you know I summarize some of the
findings some of the things I've just uh
just said
um and then uh importantly here
um the definitions again using what
other states have used you see green
hydrogen
um here it's not just the gas itself but
also the associated clean energy
generation fuel cells transmission other
infrastructure so we'll get the whole
project involved with um with hydrogen
and then you'll see the definition
starting online
. um
in a manner that produces zero carbon
and x and co-pollutant Emissions using
hydrogen fuel is electrolyzed using 100
zero carbon
emission energy source this definition
has been very carefully crafted to make
sure that it includes
Seabrook using its excess steam perhaps
to produce hydrogen which is a real
option down there and then I think
importantly because of some anxieties
people feel about the relationship of
hydrogens and natural gas note here
um that it does not include producing
hydrogen from fossil fuel feedstock
um so you'll see a little bit further
along
um green hydrogen facility they're going
to cut rather expansive definition and
then the following from that onto page
two
um the other aspects of it I will
highlight on line one storage
that is going to be an important part of
these projects I uh I believe and
regenerative fuel cells too all these
things are going to help us save money
um then you'll see in the middle of page
two there is a tax credit program here
against the business profit tax
I developed this like our r d tax credit
um and we do this in other areas and it
seemed like a short-term incentive given
the enormous benefits for us in terms of
energy and economic development and jobs
that this seemed appropriate I am
grateful to um Mr Wong from dra for
helping to work on this language he does
you know since we passed in the Senate I
think we need to just change slightly
how the tax credit is managed to make it
even more like the research and
development tax credit and I've sent
that to electronically but I have copies
of that that here
um I should mention at this point the
physical null because
you know the physical note uh says that
okay get a tax credit program however
the potential new revenues for building
this infrastructure could be quite
substantial so the physical note says
it's basically a wash as far as they can
tell at this point and that's why it
came through the through the Senate the
way uh that it did after going to our
finance
um finance committee
and then guess what another advisory
committee
and we've talked about that before and
let me talk about why
um this is important here
um it we need a green hydrogen advisory
committee in the department of injury to
do a number of things and these are the
people to do it on line 32 let me note
that Josh Elliott says we we probably
need to um add or designee and the
amendment does that on line 32 so that
it could be the designee of the site
evaluation committee
um
on that and then its duties
um let's look at the production
um
let's take a look at other existing
state and federal laws and Regulation
and funding and so they can recommend to
us some things that we might need
further to do
um what are further opportunities to
integrate green hydrogen Transportation
energy Industrial in other sectors what
barriers
may may still exist in statute
and then on lines eight through ten
um here consider a plan to create
support develop a partner with a
hydrogen hub in this state under Federal
funding provisions and determine how to
maximize federal financial incentives
support Hub development so as I said the
governor is considering this Mark
Sanborn of Des is kind of championing
this aspect of the of the bills so that
we can leverage New Hampshire perhaps in
cooperation real estates to get more
funding that's available from the
federal sources
and then um you know in terms of
construction of potential pipelines or
other otherwise I'll tell you what I was
thinking there if we're bringing in
hydrogen off of offshore wind
um we might want to be able to get that
to
Marine hydrogen terminal because the
Marine vessels are going to hydrogen we
might want to get that to
get the hydrogen out to
um we're 95 and 16 come together to have
an interstate fueling stop for trucks
maybe we want to get over to peas
because they rely on some backup
generation down at Granite Shore power
this is now run off of jet fuel and this
would be a whole lot cheaper and and uh
more environmentally friendly so that's
um what I was looking at there and then
I did want to point out lines 14 to 17
because here that
you know that kind of anxiety people
have about fossil fuel feed stock and um
let me just note that under federal
statute
it is permissible to mix up to 20
percent of hydrogen into natural gas
right now
and that is one of the projects from
that hydrogen Hub that's been proposed
including Liberty Utilities for Upstate
New York and it looks like they're going
to get a maybe 1.3 billion dollars for
that there's some potential of mixing
some hydrogen into natural gas to help a
factory out in Keene a lot of new
turbines today are developed that they
can run in hydrogen or natural gas or
combination of the both so that's why I
thought it was important to have have
this in there because this is something
people are doing it's something that you
know we've got to that is of interest
and I thought having it here would be a
would be a good place for that that
issue to get get uh uh talked about
um
and then a little bit further on I think
always important line 22
um what is this all about yes about
economic development jobs and all that
but it's the long-term interest of rate
payers cost effectively avoids or defers
distribution system costs I think that's
a pretty rock-solid principle that
whatever we're doing energy space has to
be cost effective and serve
um uh the the rate the rate payers
[Music]
um
and uh so then at the bottom of the page
um I turn to the issue of regular State
regulation
and um I don't think our state is quite
an existing structure hydrogen
like other gases is under the purview of
the local fire marshal
and it's hard for me to imagine that a
local fire marshal
um could have the expertise the
understanding or the capacity to deal
with what might be a major power plant I
mean let's say you know Merrimack
station gets replaced by hydrogen
um big big project or at the Seacoast or
elsewhere you know big project so this
is why I bring the State Fire Marshal in
here anything under 20 megawatts sure
locals could handle that but if you're
doing the big project
it really ought to it really ought to be
the State Fire Marshal will have the
capacity to uh review
um review review that uh and then lastly
I'm just a little bit of language that
implements the uh tax credit so
um I think enormous opportunity for the
state
open I want us to be open for business
um I want that investment to come here
both Federal money and private dollars
to come in and I think as I said I think
we have huge potential here
um but it's happening now and I hope we
can get ready through this Bill thank
you Mr chairman
thank you Senator questions for Senator
Waters representative Corman has a
question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Senator waters for taking my question so
going back to
um yeah page three item G lines 14
through 17. I understand what you're
saying about blending hydrogen into
existing natural gas and that it's
actually done now
um but when we talk about hydrogen
production from fossil fuel feedstock is
that still green hydrogen
not under the definition of this bill
and that's why I didn't include it in a
definition thanks for your question but
um
you know I just say in the process here
of putting this bill together there are
there's a lot of conversation a lot of
debate over what we're going to call
Green hydrogen how we're going to Define
it can we make sure seabrook's in there
we're going to do this that and there
and then obviously people are anxious
about you know this kind of
kind of sliding into
using natural gas or ammonia to do it
um but I think we've got to talk about
it and I think this is the place to do
it and you know Technologies are
changing I also what's important here to
me is that you know hydrogen is a tiny
tiny molecule right and um
and the piping you know you can't use
iron because it grows iron and so the
utilities are now going over to other
piping that can that can handle this
because it is corrosive but then you
know how are you going to handle the
Escape potential skateboard so if we're
going to be blending
I want us to be very look at it very
carefully so that we make sure those
those pipelines and and using it for
that purpose there are going to be
factories or whatever that might want to
use both fuels so that's why I put it in
here and I don't because it's an anxiety
but we ought to talk about these things
that's all
follow up right so you know I understand
about
um you know this issue about blending
and looking into that but I guess I'm
focusing more on uh using fossil fuel
feed stock
um
would would you be open to eliminating
that portion of the sentence so
basically uh line 16 putting a period
after the word uses and and removing and
consider policy recommendations for
inclusion of hydrogen production from
fossil fuel feed stocks so that it
really is
zero carbon to actually produce the
hydrogen
um thanks for your questions I'll
reiterate by definition the definition
of green hydrogen in this bill does just
what you want
this advisor group does not make policy
doesn't pass legislation
it talks and makes recommendations and I
didn't want to close off the possibility
of their Heaven discussion over it I
mean the committee will do what the
committee wants to do but my argument is
that that's the benefit of advisory
groups is that we can learn about the
Technologies we can hear the the
conversations and then it's always going
to be the legislature that decides
whether or not to allow
something else
okay uh representative Doug Thomas has a
question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh along the same
line there actually uh
representative Corman took part of my
question so I'll redirect uh in the same
area I'm a little confused um we were
passed out a
amendment that hasn't been discussed yet
all right I was gonna ask all right
hold off on that okay well then
it makes my question about paragraph G
there mute
moving on representative munz has a
question
thank you Mr chair and thank you Senator
um
on on page three
um lines eight through ten
um that that discussion about hydrogen
hub
when I when I see that and I you know
heard your your testimony that you know
that might apply
um to being a place where hydrogen from
offshore could be stored
um I'm I'm recalling the the fight to
prevent an oil refinery from being built
on the Seacoast
um
am I overreacting is this something that
you know we need to be concerned about
well thanks for the question and I use
the term hydrogen Hub because that was
that is the term in the federal law the
transportation act when that passed and
they put the initial 7.1 billion dollars
went in there create what they called
hydrogen hubs now that encompasses a lot
of things but it's a term that was used
and the
um Consortium was established out of
nyserda and I think it's like New Jersey
North through all of New England except
for us but we're considering joining
that because they thought that if we
came together we could propose projects
would have a greater
um likelihood of getting the federal
funding
so that that's why that language is in
there what does a hub mean what's going
to be project
um specific I think uh and so that's why
it ought to be looked at here and if we
join the Consortium fine if we don't uh
this group will look at the
opportunities that might be available
because I think hydrogen is going to be
a major part of Transportation
I think it's going to be a major part of
as a Storage Fuel and now how that gets
stored is going to be a good question I
know there's you know I think there's a
desire to avoid just producing it out
offshore and putting it in a pipeline to
on short
because that really there's all kinds of
issues about that of course
in Europe what we're beginning to see is
that they're producing it out at the
site and loading it onto tankers and
then it can go anywhere
and it can be taken somewhere and fed
into a power plant to produce power or
what what have you but that's something
that is the industry is developing right
now of what works best but what's going
to work best for New Hampshire I would
think you know we already have fuel
storage tanks down at the Seacoast right
and so if we have some hydrogen storage
tanks there that might be
going over to do the truck the truck
fueling or Marine hydrogen you know so
boats can come in and fuel up or that
we're you know running a 50 megawatt or
100 megawatt
which is what's existing now remember
the old wood pellet plant those become
hydrogen yeah you're going to have to
store some of the fuel but we're you
know we're already storing fuel in the
air so I don't remember answering your
question but this is why we need to have
a group that kind of looks at that
just a quick follow-up follow-up
um yeah it's probably all about what the
size of the project is in the scale of
it I mean do you have any sense at all
as to how big these quote hydrogen hubs
are
well the purple if it's actually a
question if you go online and look at
you can find
um
the list of the proposals that made the
first cut
and the 7.1 billion
um and they're all sizes all kinds of
things from small to much bigger
as I said though there are tens of
billions of dollars
in the ira
for hydrogen and treasury is not just
making rules now
um on on how the how that money can be
put out or for what kinds of projects
and we should hear pretty soon about
that and this is I mean what I'm trying
to say this is why I need the bill now
because this is coming at us is going to
be coming out as fast and as huge
amounts of money involved and I I think
this bill gives us a framework to be
able to respond to what's coming
thank you representative Doug Thomas has
a question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking this question
um I realized you were talking about we
need something this fast and everything
but I'm curious
um one of your items to consider in the
in the
commission I guess or what do we call it
advisory committee yes exactly yeah one
of many
um it says consider the construction of
a dedicated hydrogen pipeline we can't
even get a natural gas pipeline done in
the state here and hydrogen is much more
flammable than than you know propane or
natural gas
if if you want a pipeline in the state
where you ought to build a natural gas
one as well but I don't think it's
that's going to happen either so why why
even consider it nobody wants it
um thanks for your question and I look
pretty closely at what some other states
are doing
and we've got a new industry coming and
is recognition that you know there's
going to be need to be some
transportation
of this I don't think we're going to see
a big hydrogen network but we might see
a pipeline from the port over to peas
or you know locally around there and the
questions that you're raising are
important ones do note that the bill
clarifies too that this these this
hydrogen infrastructure is going to be
going through the SEC
and so we will have a place that you
know a responsibility there for figuring
out what should and can't be done with
this new technology and the associated
infrastructure
I will say that I think I share all our
frustrations whether one likes one kind
of power source or not I don't want New
Hampshire to be the black hole where
industry says don't go there because you
can't get anything built it it if we're
going to lower energy costs we need to
consider
the these kinds of things and I and I
think there's a way forward on this
uh representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um is thank you for this for being here
this bill is interesting a lot of
hydrogen energy is being generated from
waste from garbage does this bill in any
way address that methodology either
through the bill itself or through the
advisory committee uh thanks for the
question no this is hydrogen not methane
no hydrogen is being yeah okay
okay
thank you representative lewicki has a
question
right
well thanks for the question and um you
know there's there's a lot of great
research and reports from the EPA and
Department of the federal department of
energy on their Pro their projections on
the cost of hydrogen production
and um it's very it's very interesting
what they're saying there's a couple
things related to your question one is
that the technology is going to improve
so the amount of electricity needed
to do the electrolyzing is going to be
reduced so it becomes more more cost
effective so it's kind of like with the
solar panel thing solar panels were
super expensive now they're pretty cheap
and they think that that trajectory over
the next few years for the methodology
of electrolyzing is going to be is not
going to use so much power the second
part of it though is that you know
because of the green hydrogen definition
here what is anticipated
is that you're going to have cheap
source of electricity
that will make this possible number one
I think will be offshore wind
because that that has the potential to
produce a whole lot of hydrogen and it
can electrolyzes out of salt water right
at the turbines and then the other is
solar I mean let's say
that you had a coal plant somewhere and
you were going to take it down and
replace it with two or three turbines
run by hydrogen and you're going to
generate
the energy to do that with a couple
hundred acres of solar on site
that's the kind that's those are the
kind of numbers that will can work for
this and I think that's what New
Hampshire could see
um
so I have a couple questions Senator
with regard to the tax credit
now the production tax credits and
investment tax credits created at the
federal level for wind and solar were
envisioned to be temporary
they kept getting renewed and renewed
and renewed and finally in the inflation
reduction act they were made permanent
you mentioned in your testimony that
there are tax credits for green hydrogen
that go up to 36 percent I think you
said apparently so
my question would be why do we need a
New Hampshire business profits tax
credit if there are all these federal
tax credits available for green hydrogen
since we know from past experience the
tax credits never go away because once
an industry becomes dependent upon them
they're never going to let them go
so my question would be why would we
want to
subject our local New Hampshire business
profits tax to that kind of a situation
um thanks thanks for your uh question
and that's really kind of in two parts
let me answer the second part first
there's a
you know 2029
this is over have to be renewed by the
legislature legislature will decide I've
had a you know my CTE tax credit program
I put through that's been renewed and
there's another
there's another r d one that has been
renewed a couple of times but that's
what ways and means should decide
um at each time and I personally only
like tax credits of this sort
at the startup phase
now why do we need one in the state
um it's hard to know the vagaries of the
relationship between the federal tax
credits and what how an industry
our project might it might apply or
might not account for certain certain
parts of it you know in what
relationship that might have to tax
credits it can be
achieved locally
this industry can go anywhere
and I think it signals that the state is
willing to have a little skin in the
game here
um because we see the benefits
the the potential investment the jobs
the increase of the tax base
here I I think are worth our making that
relatively small investment here as as
an incentive I should mention as well
because I didn't before Mr chairman that
um these projects will also be eligible
for 72 colon 74 if the local
municipality wants to do the tax
deferral
um as they do for other businesses it
doesn't mandate it but it makes that
possible just so see I just thought
these were two two little we have these
little methods we use them for other
other things and it's a it's an
opportunity for us you know to again to
Signal our partnership with people in
state who want to make these Investments
or potentially people from out of state
okay so you're not concerned at all then
about the potential for these becoming
permanent
well I'm a legislator you're a
legislator not to be facetious Mr
chairman but we get to decide this one
says they go bye-bye in 2029 which seems
like a reasonable five-year period
see if they get adopted and if they're
useful or not
okay
there's no questions for the senator
saying none let's move on
we still have other folks we want to
hear from and we're actually going to
hear next from a couple of members of
our committee because
they have amendments that they want to
introduce
okay thank you they have amendments
since they want to introduce to this
bill so let's have representative McGee
tell us about her Amendment and then
we'll have representative Kaplan tell us
about his Amendment
actually representative if you just want
to do it from here that's fine with me
save us all a little time
the amendment I handed out to the
committee is amendment number
1345 H and it's an amendment to Simply
amend RSA 362 as inserted by Section 3
of the bill by deleting sub paragraph G
and renumbering the original sub
paragraphs H through k
uh
and so what what they did
um it's not exactly what I asked them to
do actually but uh sub paragraph G is on
page three at line 14 and that's the
um sentence that starts with consider
facilities that result in the blending
of hydrogen into existing natural gas
transmission and Distribution Systems
that serve residential commercial
transportation and Industrial uses
and it was actually I asked them to put
a period there and remove the
parenthetical phrase which was added as
part of an amendment to the original
Senate bill that says and consider
policy recommendations for inclusion of
hydrogen production from fossil fuel
feedstock the reason that I wanted that
portion of the sentence
removed is because it is inconsistent
with the definition as Senator Waters
reference which is on page one line 24.
uh which says that the term does not the
term does not include hydrogen produced
using stream steam forming uh or any
other conversion technology that
produces hydrogen from fossil fuel
feedstock so while I do understand the
explanation that the senator gave us
saying that we should investigate
whether there would be instances where
it would make sense I think if we are
passing a bill relative to Green
hydrogen energy
that we should do our best to keep it
green and
um you know
my understanding is that the process of
creating hydrogen you know it's always
going to require an energy source in
order to split the oxygen and the
hydrogen but um
the reason that we are pursuing hydrogen
is because it's non-emitting and so
once we open up the option of including
gas as a source of creating the hydrogen
then we've kind of negated the purpose
of pursuing hydrogen and that's
certainly just my opinion on the subject
but so my bill is my Amendment to the
bill is just designed to take that out
for consideration of this particular
bill
thank you representative Kaplan you want
to discuss your Amendment thank you Mr
chair
so
um
my Amendment well first of all I want to
thank the senator for bringing a
what is a great Bill to to our committee
and a forward-looking bill and I agree
it's gonna
allow for the establishment of very
important green hydrogen uh
infrastructure and maybe even
manufacturing and certainly
transportation in our state so it's a
it's an important bill it's an important
fuel source as we move to a zero carbon
economy so thank you Senator I I just
wanted to offer this amendment to take
care of some uh perhaps unintentional
consequences that come if we're not
careful with our definition of of what
is green hydrogen so I agree with
representative McKee that um
hydrogen produced from fossil fuel could
not be considered green even by the
definition of this of the statute that's
before us and actually hydrogen from
natural gas is extremely carbon
intensive it for every pound of hydrogen
produced you get 9 to 12 pounds of
carbon dioxide emissions so it's uh it's
not what what we need if we're concerned
with transitioning to a zero carbon
economy it certainly doesn't have a
place in a bill that's designed to
incentivize green hydrogen so my
Amendment
uh just strikes that language
that comes in uh
on page three uh section uh
the uh sorry page four under the duties
of the advisory committee
line uh
16-17 It just strikes everything after
the comma about considering policy
recommendations for including hydrogen
produced from fossil fuels feedstock
mine's just just simply strikes that
that Clause out
uh in addition uh just to be safe you
know just
uh there's there's us there's also other
language on line six
lines 14 18 and 20 that reference
hydrogen as opposed to Green hydrogen so
my my Amendment just basically replaces
hydrogen with the word Green in front of
the hydrogen so we know we're talking
about Green hydrogen all throughout the
language of this bill
um and then so the other thing that my
Amendment does is on the first page
under Section 7 definition of green
hydrogen I add a line
after
uh
line 24 of the year of the original bill
after a zero carbon emission energy
source I add the clause
uh that is additional to the regional
electric grid infrastructure as of July
1st 2023 or independent of the regional
electric grid and the reason I add that
is because
say you have a seabro and the senator
mentioned this himself say you have a
Seabrook Nuclear Station that is
interested in the subsidies and the tax
credits available for green hydrogen and
decides instead of selling their energy
into the you know forward Market or the
iso they're going to sign a PPA with a
green hydrogen hub
that would actually increase our carbon
emissions because what would replace the
nuclear on our default Service uh you
know it would probably be natural gas
maybe even coal so that would have the
unintended consequence of actually
raising our carbon emissions which is
not the purpose of pursuing green
hydrogen so I I just thought that any
kind of energy source that would be
under the definition of green hydrogen
would have to be something that's
additional to the grid and that's that's
actually what the European commission
includes in their definition of green
hydrogen uh so that's why I have that
language there
um
so I mean I think that it's a great bill
it could be improved and uh you know I'm
looking forward to working with the
committee on
on strengthening this bill whether we
choose a you know line Amendment
representative mcgeesman or we or some
other router we decided to throw it out
altogether but I welcome the senator for
bringing this forward
so Senator Waters could you come back up
to the table and do a couple of things
for us
number one give us your reaction to
these two proposed amendments
well my reaction is I respect the wisdom
of this committee
um as a senator and uh I understand what
is being said here I think that the
um
you know the a lot of discussion about
trying to get
Confluence on a green hydrogen plant and
that the folks who wanted to have other
natural gas were happy to see that we at
least could talk about it but I
understand what's being said about
striking that that that and um I I
understand where that's coming from and
if that's the way it needs to go I
respect your you know the the vote of
this committee on I'm not sure that I
quite followed the parts about what why
the part on the first page was needed I
just
I want to be sure that steam production
of hydrogen that might be possible at
Seabrook is included
as a possibility for producing green
hydrogen I think that's important I I
think it's a good that's wasted energy
otherwise and um I I think it can help
us too in producing hydrogen there that
then can be very useful to us so I I'm
sorry representative I didn't I couldn't
quite hear and follow what was being
done there if you think that some
language changes needs to be made to
clarify some things you want great but
that's just my Proviso there let's just
make sure that because that that that
that definition is worked on carefully
with next next era and I just don't want
to kind of get in a position where we're
we're kind of excluding them from be
able to do do something
okay and number two just as I was
acknowledging these two folks over here
you handed me some Amendment texts is
this text that you want us to consider
yes thank you and what it is is this is
from Mr Wong who maybe I don't know if
he's still here to he may be are you
going to testify yeah so it was the the
in in looking again at it they said they
needed to just shift chain make some
changes the language about how the tax
credit worked and that's what's there he
also wants to make sure that the
expiration date remember there is an
expiration date
um Accords with the tax year rather than
the date that I put on it so and then um
Josh Elliott pointed out that we needed
to add or designee to the um
the chair of the SEC
okay great so we will have three
amendments to consider when the time
comes representative Doug Thomas
thank you Mr thank you for taking my
question uh what you just mentioned
about Seabrook uh you you the reason for
leaving that in there is this
possibility of of some of their steam
could be used for is that a
it is that a a a practical or a or a
political
um uh uh way to make sure that you know
you know Seabrook may like to make some
money off of uh this process and if they
were able to participate in this they
would be more more willing to
participate and and help with this uh
thanks for coming this is purely
practical I I the technology is such
that there are there is capacity to make
hydrogen using the steam power and
that's that's a good thing and and
Seabrook has Steam so it has nothing to
do with political it's just you know
practical possibilities that's because
we have Seabrook that this would be
useful this could be useful for him yeah
and for us uh what I what I meant by
political was that it it enables them to
maybe
um help in in getting this green uh
green hydrogen uh project going uh
knowing that they will be able to uh
participate yeah and profit from it yeah
thanks for that that part see you know
we're all waiting for the treasury
Department to drop the final regulations
and Rule making on how that money is
going to come be coming out of the IRA
and I but I do know from I had some
conversation with some federal officials
a few weeks ago that um you know that
there there is there are particular
incentives for taking existing power
plants and and being able to either
transition transition them or utilize
them towards green hydrogen production
so I would hope that this would again I
I if we could do something to help set
us up to leverage some of that money so
we can get investment here that's what
the bill is for
okay thank you senator now let's get the
dra perspective here I'm going to ask Mr
King Wing Mong to come and talk to us
along with um
um just a second I got your card here
somewhere Lauren O'Sullivan right
so let's get the DS dra's perspective on
uh both the change that Senator Waters
and apparently you folks uh would like
to see and your general observations
about uh
this portion of the bill thank you good
afternoon my name is Keane Ming Wong
text policy Council of the dra
and I'm Lauren O'Sullivan senior
Financial Analyst at the dra
the department does not have a position
on this bill but seeing that uh there is
a tax credit component uh to the BPT so
uh the department has taken a position
to uh sort of try to ensure that the
language in the bill is workable to to
administer the business profits tax
credit that's available first off uh we
do think that the um the green hydrogen
facility is also would qualify as a
utility property and potentially be
subject to the utility property tax
um and then so on to us to the uh the
business profits tax credit as Senator
Waters mentioned that he wanted to model
this credit against the BPT uh similar
to the research and development credit
that's currently available and the way
it works is that that is a cap amount of
uh credit that's available to be given
out to all to the pool of applicants
within any fiscal year
according to this uh proposed bill here
that pool of credit available is five
million dollars per fiscal year and
therefore in order for us to make a
determination
if there are applicants who applications
that might come in that at the total of
the fiscal year might exited 5 million
we would then need to collect all the
applications first and then run our
calculation and then if there's an if
the amount of credit is being applied
for excess of five million we need to
prorate that to each of the applicants
um so the the way it's structured right
now is
if tax if year one is when the uh the
the utility incurred a cost it would
actually then apply to against the
business profits tax on the second year
so the credit would then apply to the
second year so it's not to the first is
the second year
so and we
drive to some language in terms of the
the business profits tax credit uh what
I did not mention to Senator Waters
earlier on and then what he did mention
just now after I spoke to him was that
we wanted to add additional language to
the end of the bill
uh in regards to the cessation of the
the BPT credit which would be on page
four
line 12.
so section 7 effective date for Section
6 section six which is the repeal of the
uh the credit against the BPT
currently it says section six of his
actual ticket effect January 1 2029
we're going to propose that that the
committee considered changing that
language to session six of this egg
shell be effective taxable periods
ending on or after December 31 2029 so
it coincides with a textbook period as
opposed to just a
so it's clearer that when um when the
credit would cease to be available
so you said on or after January 1st on
or after so so you would read taxable uh
section 6 of this act shall take uh
shall be effective
taxable periods ending on or after
December 31 2029
okay thank you thank you
anything else uh
nope that that's uh pretty much it
okay questions for these folks
representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
um you mentioned that the the pool of
BPT tax credit is 5 million annually I'm
assuming it's a lapsing fund and it gets
replenished is it generally 5 million or
has it been for some time
or is it does it fluctuate
foreign
the way it was proposed that the cap is
5 million for every uh fiscal year
from when it started so um it's that cap
is not going to change not to my
knowledge okay and follow up
follow up and so you have no way of
knowing whether the 5 million will be
tapped and you're saying if if you get
more requests for credit than you have
then you just prorate what's there and
make sure it goes out to everybody
that's applied that type of thing yes
and and the maximum credit would be five
million yep
is that I'm sorry did that answer your
question so 5 million could go to one
one project uh no so it also says here
um
the amount of credit which shall be used
to offset the business profits tax
liability this is in the amended
language that Senator Waters sentence
yes
um
for subsequent Tax Repair shall be 10 of
the qualifying cost and shall not exceed
500 000 for any taxable period okay so
for any any one applicant yeah yeah
clear thank you
okay additional questions
representative not her
thank you just uh for the record how do
you spell your last name
w-o-n-g oh thank you I forgot what your
name was I knew it I wouldn't have had
to ask that's fine
okay so if I understand it correctly
then that this bill because it provides
for a six-year tax credit
of five million dollars no more than
five million dollars a year that would
be a 30 million dollar tax credit over
the life of this program
I believe it would actually be more like
a five-year
um
yeah so 25 million okay thank you
additional questions
seeing none thanks to you folks for
being here thank you appreciate your
patience it's been a long day I know
now we'll hear from Griffin Roberge from
the Department of energy to get the
Department's perspective on this
legislation
fancy meeting you here
thank you uh Mr chairman
um I know there are a number of
amendments kicking around I'm going to
try to keep it simple
um department is neutral to the bill as
amended by the Senate no comments
underneath the Amendments uh heck that I
haven't seen
um
obviously the bill is obviously a tax
policy Bill we are not a tax agency dra
was here to answer questions so we'll
defer any feedback
um
on the tax policy provisions of this
bill
um I think Senator Waters has spoken
quite a bit uh regarding the definitions
um in the bill I think the Departments
only observation will be pertaining to
section 3 of the bill which begins on
page I'm sorry uh deals with the
advisory committee established under
section three of the bill that's page
two
line 26.
um as noted in the fiscal note the
department
does feel that uh what is it um would
not have a creating this advisory
committee would not have
um any type of fiscal impact however in
talking internally the department does
feel that uh the legislature should
maybe consider creating a legislative
study committee rather than an Advisory
Group to examine these issues earlier I
would have suggested a study commission
but I realized that the House and Senate
have different rules on that regarding
legislative makeup but we defer on that
on that on that front to the to the
legislature
um
we would we submit that obviously this
advisory committee has a lot of agency
heads
um as I think has been expressed earlier
in site evaluation committee testimony
we're a little bit leery of of uh
engaging advisory committees that are
heavily dependent on full-time agency
heads taking the lead or designees that
come on and off as time goes on so we
figure maybe a legislative study
committee might be something to suggest
here if that is not of interest to the
committee
um I would respectfully suggest going a
little further and making one slight
amendment to The Advisory advisory
committee and that is striking entirely
The Language online 32.
um the chair of the site evaluation
committee for two reasons one I know
when Senator Waters Amendment he
suggested uh putting or designee as is
under statute right now the chair of the
SEC is the chair of the puc
we are just concerned about giving a
member potentially two votes on a
committee
um and even with the or designee
language it still invites the potential
for that occurring
um that's one reason the second reason
is there's also a duty for the commit
for the advisory committee in uh
considering the construction of a
dedicated hydrogen pipeline or network
of pipelines to serve users of hydrogen
to the extent that that might require
site evaluation committee approval I
don't think we want a member of the site
evaluation committee giving giving
feedback on that
um with that
um happy to take any questions that
folks might have
thank you questions for the Department
representative lewicki has one okay
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
robash
how much hydrogen infrastructure exists
in New Hampshire today if I had a tanker
truckload of hydrogen who would buy it
who could use it sure and and thank
thank you for the question I don't think
I have an immediate answer to that but I
would Circle back to Senator Waters
comments is that certainly there is
um a big potential for an expansion of
this type of energy technology in the
future
um
trying to measure out what may or may
not occur in the state of New Hampshire
in the future I couldn't guess
um I could certainly ask around the
department to follow up with you on your
specific questions
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um you just said that the chair of the
SEC is also the chair of the puc is that
always or just currently nope that's all
that thank you for the question first
off
um that's always been okay the case in
State Statute okay thank you
additional questions for the Department
seeing none
thank you Vaughn
thank you
and call on our last speaker on this
bill that's Mr kwasnick from Concord
welcome back to sdne
it has
happened
me too
purchase
um I
I will dispenser the bio because I think
you've heard it before and it's on the
on this testimony but um thank you for
allowing me to come before you today uh
I am in support of this bill and I'm
acting as a sole individual I'm not
representing any other organization
um I support this bill you'll hear some
common commonalities of what you've
heard before this bill provides
excellent basis for adding green
hydrogen facilities and infrastructure
to enable renewable energy generation in
New Hampshire
it provides a much-needed definition of
green hydrogen in its production from
clean energy resources
and green energy or excuse me green
hydrogen has a potential service of as
Senator Waters said as a Storage Fuel
from offshore wind energy that's thus
solving the intermittency issue of
onshore offshore wind it also increase
the reliability of electric generation
and
um it's it's also fairly well known that
green hydrogen can also be reformed into
ammonia
uh they're chemically similar ammonia
has hydrogen in it with nitrogen and in
fact it's used as is transportation fuel
in in shipping and we're seeing in other
foreign markets where uh hydrogen is
actually being converted ammonia then
ship being shipped to places like Japan
where then it's reformed back to
hydrogen it's a much simpler fuel Taxi
transport not as hazardous as just a
hydrogen itself
and I did uh my my um
um support for this this bill is subject
to the same amendment that was proposed
by uh representative McGee and that's
that section 2G for the advisory
committee and to remove the language uh
quote unquote and consider policy
recommendations for inclusion of
hydrogen production from fossil fuel
feedback and I think that is
inconsistent with the intention of of
this proposal
and that concludes my testimony thank
you very much appreciate it questions
for Mr quasnick
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair
um this uh is going to piggyback on a
question that representative Doug Thomas
asked earlier
um if we if we go to this hydrogen as a
field Source we're going to have to have
pipelines do you see any pushback in New
Hampshire on establishing new pipelines
um I think we've all been down the road
it might be an extremely difficult thing
to do yeah but keep in mind that
elsewhere around the world especially in
the UK
um oh what number the pipelines in the
UK are being converted from natural gas
to hydrogen transmission
so there was some compatibility within
those debt infrastructure that's
currently in the ground so I wouldn't
write off our current infrastructure as
being also supported transmission of
hydrogen and and to also um address the
issue about a hydrogen Hub
um that's a technology and actually term
used in the in the um the current
natural gas transmission Market you've
probably heard of the term Henry Hudson
Hub it's a hub down in New York City
where they basically use that as the
pricing mechanism for for methane uh
natural gas so a hub of this nature for
for hydrogen perhaps using the same
infrastructure we have in place could
actually be a concept that could
actually work I have a follow-up
follow up thank you
um what would a hydrogen leak look like
hmm
it's a you can't see it well okay I
think it's odorless
and you probably know after it's all
released and you might have an explosion
so it's a highly inflammable gas
it's very reactive it wants to go back
to being part of water
and that process is very energy
emitting process so how do you identify
it there are special instrument
instruments like they use for methane
for natural gas but is there land
contamination I'm sorry land
contamination that wouldn't be a problem
because it's a gas okay
evolves into the atmosphere not in this
world thank you sorry
representative Reynolds ask a question
um thank you Mr chairman another
follow-up to
representative Wendy Thomas's question
about the referenced opposition passed
opposition to
new pipelines do you think it's possible
that a significant part of such
opposition to pipelines in the past was
do
to the fact that
those proposals represented
massive investment in fossil fuel
infrastructure which would then be
socialized and which would then be
required to be paid off in other words
those Investments would have locked us
into that use of that fossil fuel for 30
to 50 years and that's why at least some
of that opposition was so vociferous I'm
not an expert on pipelines but I think
there is some some truth to that many
people have looked at natural gas as a
transition fuel to a carbon-free uh
energy environment sometime in the later
part of this first half of the century
so I think many people in opposition
those pipelines didn't want to see those
stranded costs being put in the ground
and then would continue the industry for
many years into the future
there may be less opposition to
pipelines that have hydrogen because
it's a climate-friendly fuel so there
may indeed be less opposition to that
but right this at this point for me it's
supposition thank you
representative lewicki has a question
okay thank you Mr chairman actually it's
just a point of clarification since
hydrogen is lighter than air it is less
likely to explode than a heavier than
air gas like methane which will puddle
dehydrogen will go up and it's likely to
do no more than ignite and it's not
likely to explode
thank you for that point of
clarification a physics experiment right
yes
seeing no further questions I want to
thank you for being here to help us
understand the issues involved and
Senate Bill 167. thank you and seeing I
that I have no more pink cards I'm going
to close the public hearing on Senate
Bill 167 and conclude our activity for
the day I'll remind members that we're
meeting again next Monday the 17th of
April and potentially next Tuesday the
18th
that will depend almost entirely on how
long it takes us to get through the
remaining Senate bills I believe there
are three of them
because we want to do an exact session
after that so if it takes us six hours
to get through those three bills then we
may not finish our exact session on
Monday we may carry over into Tuesday
I'm going to notice it for both days
representative McGee you had a question
yes thank you Mr chair I wanted to
revisit the concept of having a work
session on Senate bill 166.
we said we would discuss it after but if
we break now and don't come back till
Monday we will we'll have lost another
week so I'm just wondering whether
there's any place that we can fit in a
time for that and add it to the schedule
so we can discuss it before we exec it
um
why don't I schedule the work session on
one
66 for the first order of business next
Monday
and we can spend an hour talking about
it and then we'll do the public hearings
on the remaining Senate bills how's that
that'll be great and in order to do it
in that amount of time I hope people
will do their homework and come prepared
to talk about what they think should be
in the bill if anything
okay representative Munns I had a
question yeah thank you Mr chair I was
going to ask similar question about 167
I mean there seems to be a lot of
amendments floating around on that on
that is that worth having a work session
or subcommittee to try to craft a single
amendment that potentially would work
well we do need to craft a single
Amendment because you can't come out of
committee with multiple amendments
you can't do floor amendments like you
can on the house floor so we do need a
single Amendment whether it's a
combination of the McGee Kaplan and
Waters Amendment or
some different Amendment we do need an
amendment
um why not I let since the two of you
proposed an amendment why don't I let
you guys work out what a joint Amendment
would look like you have a copy of
Senator Waters Amendment
okay
okay I'll get you one representative
Corman thank you uh Mr chairman I was
wondering were we going to get the blue
sheet and online numbers for the four
bills that we heard today representative
closure would give those to us if he
were here but he's not uh you want to do
it
okay I'm happy to do it sure uh go see
represent
um Christy officer our
committee researchers she'll give you
the information
so let me find a copy of the senator
Waters Amendment
would you hand this to representative
McGee
thank you
okay
in the case
Okay Senator I mean representative
Corman will give us I don't have the
numbers yet Christie's writing them down
I'm just wondering I'm holding things up
uh would you rather I just give the
numbers another time
yes let's let's do them Monday morning
okay so now we're officially adjourned
for the day I'll see you on Monday
goodbye